this is real there is an intelligence
Source by the name of David grush who
has come forward saying that he is aware
of a crash retrieval program that has
been illegally kept secret from the
American public he's also alleged by the
way bodies
Ross coldheart is a world-renowned
investigative journalist who's built a
career reporting on issues ranging from
war to corporate malfeasance to what
brings us here today namely the UAP
topic his work includes award-winning
documentaries for instance many of them
from the 60 Minutes Australia as well as
the UFO phenomenon Ross has a notable
book titled in plain sight which serves
as a fantastic sober no fluff
introduction to the subject and links as
usual to everything is in the
description recently Ross has made
headlines for his interview with UFO
whistleblower David grush a former
member of the all domain anomaly
resolution office also known as arrow
and the National geospatial Intelligence
Agency where grush made claims about the
existence of non-human origin Vehicles
as well as even bodies that interview
gained worldwide attention the last
interview with Ross on the theories of
everything podcast is one of the most
viewed of all of the podcasts on toe
needless to say this episode second part
with Ross is one of the most requested
my name is Kurt J mungle and I have a
podcast here called theories of
everything where I use my background in
mathematical physics to analyze theories
of everything predominantly from a
theoretical physics perspective though
I'm interested in other approaches as to
what's fundamental is presentism correct
what about holism over reductionism what
about Consciousness where does
experience come into play what
ontological status does mathematics have
you can think of it as explorations of
the largest Mysteries of the universe
without already having some defined
position that I'm advocating for and
trying to force the conversation in a
contrived way toward it at approximately
the 20 to 30 minute Mark there will be a
couple of ads those drastically helped
toe as well as the patrons you'll also
get audio episodes like this ad free and
early for instance this episode was
released a couple days ago prior to it
premiering on YouTube as a thank you to
the patrons so thank you to the sponsors
and thank you to the patrons if you'd
like to support theories of everything
this podcast then visit patreon.com
kurtjimungle that's
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l with a
donation of whatever you like it
genuinely helps it helps both
financially as well as emotionally that
is motivationally to know that there are
other people like yourself who are
willing to support a project like this
to bring it to other people to thousands
to even millions of people at zero cost
that's super fantastic so thank you
thank you to all the patrons and thank
you to you who are watching enjoy this
podcast with Ross coldheart
good morning Kurt well Ross how's your
morning going
my morning is terrific Kurt I'm having
my first cup of coffee and it's bitterly
cold here in Australia where I live uh
probably a bit warmer where you are but
um I'm very very happy because I've just
seen the Douglas Dean Johnson report on
some legislation that I've known is
coming for a while which is the um Jilla
brand Amendment which essentially
requires holders of non-earth origin or
exotic UAP materials they give them six
months to make it available to Arrow the
pentagon's UAP investigation office and
whilst it's dry and Dusty legislation
it's extraordinarily significant to see
the Pentagon
putting in black and white text
references to non-human origin
technology
essentially it's an explicit admission
of what people like myself and David
grush the UAP witness have known for
some considerable time that there are
witnesses that have come forward to the
Congress oversight committees notably
the house permanent Select Committee for
intelligence and also the Senate Select
Committee for intelligence and multiple
Witnesses whether the debunkers
denialists want to know it or not have
given evidence about their knowledge of
a legacy crash retrieval and reverse
engineering program
that is in operation right now that your
Country Canada is involved in and I
think slowly but surely we are
incrementally getting closer to an
acknowledgment that there is a truce
behind all of this
you said that you and David Rush know
about do you feel as if you know this
I've been in the um difficult position
even the first time that I spoke to you
of having confidential sources who are
not yet prepared to go public and
um uh in recent times David grush of
course has been one of them
people who support his contention that
there is a crash retrieval program that
has been in existence for some
considerable time
involving the retrieval of non-human
technology and that there has been
secret agreements within the five eyes
Alliance for the retrieval of that
technology and more importantly that the
United States in collaboration with
other countries has been involved in the
attempted reverse engineering of that
technology and yes I have multiple
Witnesses who purport to be
knowledgeable about the Legacy UAP crash
retrieval and reverse engineering
program
including David grush who are at the
right time prepared to come forward with
their evidence evidence other than
testimonial coming
um yeah there probably will be I mean I
think a lot depends frankly on how the
Congress handles it from here
I'll be honest with you my friend I'm
very skeptical quite slim glum at the
moment about
um the possibilities that the Congress
is going to run with this
uh I do see and hear from Individual
representatives and Senators who are
dedicated
and determined to get to the truth of
this matter
but I think that there are competing
interests here you have to I mean I
don't want to sound like some wacky
conspiracy theorist but the reality is
that the the military and the
intelligence community in the United
States are an extremely formidable and
Powerful Lobby in the chorus
many congressmen and senators are
reliant on support from that industry
for their continued re-election
including people who sit on the
respective committees in the Congress
and really I think at the moment where
we're at at the moment is
you have
since David grush went public a few
weeks ago
you have people in the skeptic debunker
camp and quite rightly I think saying
well where's the evidence
and debunkers quite rightly say well he
hasn't provided any yet
but I think there's a bit of willful
blindness going on there people are
ignoring the fact that Mr grush legally
faces criminal prosecution if he reveals
the full extent of what he knows and
about which he has testified not only to
the two Congressional intelligence
committees but also to the Inspector
General of defense and the Inspector
General of the intelligence community
and I don't want to sound like a
long-winded lawyer and I really think I
have to keep on saying this until until
the sun goes down but the simple fact is
uh his evidence has been provided under
oath to the relevant government agencies
and committees that are entitled to hear
it and I respect and understand why
there are officials in our intelligence
and community community and defense
Community who want to keep certain
aspects highly confidential I can
actually understand why they're doing
that knowing what I know not from David
grush but from other sources I can
understand why certain things certain
Technologies certain potential
weaponries certain capabilities are
being kept confidential what I do find
increasingly bewildering
is the reluctance of mainstream media to
acknowledge a growing reality
I've just this morning read a stupid
piece written by a columnist in my
national newspaper in Australia the
Australian newspaper and it's a column
entitled space aliens are everywhere oh
wait
and essentially it's a piss take it's a
um it's an attack on so-called
conspiracists
uh who've um
uh said that the Pentagon knows all
about UFOs but have withheld it from the
president and the Congress preferring to
exploit the non-human technology and
essentially it's a piss take it's a
laugh a whole idea the whole concept
that there might be some veracity to
this
and the thing that really shocks me is I
guess I'm lucky because I've been
talking to people now for several years
who had a knowledge of this program I've
been knocked out it exists and people
can call me a tinfor head crazy as much
as they like
but the simple fact is it's real
and it's slowly but surely dribbling out
I've spoken to senators and
representatives in the Congress and
staffers who've told me that they have
been in the room when credible Witnesses
have given evidence multiple Witnesses
have given evidence about retrieved
non-human technology
so my friend the only question in my
mind and I'm very very skeptical in
light of the ridiculous blowback from
even people in the UFO UAP Community who
should know better skills for the
Pentagon people who are conspiring in
the cover-up
there is a real problem at the moment in
getting mainstream media engagement on
this issue and it's not that there's
some dark conspiracy there's not some
intelligence service Black Men in Black
telling editors not to run the story
what this is is a residual stigma a
taboo that's been attached to this
subject so well and the hilarious thing
is I'm actually talking to people in the
military who want this story out from
within the high levels at the Pentagon
who are frustrated that the national
mainstream media is not engaging with
this issue they are incredulous that the
disinformation campaign has been so
effective that you've now got newspapers
like the New York Times And The
Washington Post either dismissing or
passing or taking their time dragging
their feet on deciding whether or not
they want to investigate the allegations
of a man like David grush
frankly mate I don't know what's going
on in the National newspapers in the U.S
Canada or in Australia and the UK and
most of the world's major newspapers
anymore when an intelligence Insider of
the caliber of David grush comes forward
somebody who has indubitable
credible credentials who the Pentagon in
the three or four weeks since he went
public
has not laid a glove on his credibility
don't you think don't you think if there
was anything that they could pull out of
the cupboard to attack David Rush with
the Pentagon would have done by now they
are desperately trying to plug the leaks
and stop this from coming out
they're terrified that they are involved
and indeed according to Mr grush
involved in a potentially criminal
conspiracy
there are people at the highest levels
of the Pentagon who have knowingly
covered up and concealed from the
Congress knowledge of and non-human
intelligence and they've done this for
80 plus years
and the thing that is fascinating to me
is we now have legislation that my
colleague and friend Douglas Dean
Johnson has written about today
which specifically states that there's
now a bill written by Senator Kirsten
gillibrand which gives holders of
non-earth origin or exotic UAP material
essentially an amnesty to come forward
with what they know why would Congress
demand the necessity for such
legislation if they didn't know
something and what is going wrong with
the Curiosity of the world's greatest
newspapers this is not as some charge a
tinfoil hat conspiracy theory don't buy
into the line that this is some
spurious allegation made by some wacky
ill-informed intelligence operative this
is somebody David grushes somebody who
at the very highest levels of the U.S
intelligence Community was cleared to
Top Secret
compartmented intelligence more than 2
000 special access programs
this is a guy with one of the highest
clearances in the U.S intelligence
Community who was tasked by a
congressional mandate to go out as part
of the UAP task force to investigate the
phenomenon to find out the truth of what
America really knows
and you know what he found he found a
hidden crash retrieval Legacy UFO
reverse engineering program that's been
going on since the 1940s and 50s
and frankly I'm at the stage at the
moment where if America's mainstream
media and political leadership doesn't
want to engage with this issue
then let them deny it
and if the American public don't care
about it
let them get on with their their lives
because
inherently at the heart of all of this
and I know you have a lot of scientists
in your community of watches Kurt
I'm talking to people inside the Legacy
program who tell me frustratedly with
great emotion how much as scientists
they care about the fact that this
knowledge is being kept from a huge
chunk of the human race
but only a select Cadre of people inside
the intelligence and Military
establishment are privy to this
information
and they think they tell me it's
unwarranted it's unjustifiable
they acknowledge that we should not let
our potential adversaries Russia China
North Korea Iran gain access to such
dangerous Technologies
but they see no reason why the human
race can't be told what they tell me is
the truth which is Iran nihis non-human
intelligences that have been engaging
with this planet for many many thousands
of years thousands not tens of thousands
oh well I can't specify tens of
thousands I've just you know it would be
more than tens of thousands I mean
they've been with us for for time
immemorial I'm told
now Millions
that's your that's your words my friend
I don't know I don't know for sure but
the the simple fact is
I'm kind of
I'm bored with this debate at the moment
you know I I I I don't care anymore I
just think
you know people
there's a fundamental failure here of
oversight I know a lot of people are
going to get excited with what this new
legislation says and I want to deal with
that because I think it's important that
we talk about it
but I have a gut feeling that congress's
heart is not in this
and that the lobby the powerful military
Lobby that wants this suppressed is
winning
and sure enough they've got their shills
out there in social media they've got
their friends in the media you know
every National Security correspondent is
being told on the QT stay away from this
one on the QT on the quiet
um
um can you explain how this works
yeah sure I mean I mean I mean I've
reported on National Security issues the
thing I find hilarious is let's use an
analogy let's talk about what happened
at the time of the last Gulf War shortly
after the al-Qaeda attacks 2002 2003.
for some reason that has never been even
now fully properly explained Al-Qaeda
became Iraq
and Afghanistan and we ended up
launching totally disastrous Wars into
both of those countries based on
intelligence from
sources okay
now ask yourself
credulous National Security reporters
who have since been hung out to drive
for their failure to do their job
properly
accepted assurances from the CIA from
Cole Powell and his testimony to the U.N
this was an important moment where the
world was essentially strict into going
to war against Saddam Hussein on the
false claim that he had weapons of mass
destruction in the Iraqi desert
that was all sourced back largely in
part to one guy called curveball that
was his code name curveball a guy based
I think somewhere in Germany who was a
refugee and it turned out he was a put
up by the Iraqi National Congress who
were essentially
um a group that were largely aligned
with Iran
and because of credulous National
Security reporters not doing their job
a source led the world to war in the
Middle East
billions of dollars have been expended
in an unnecessary War hundreds of
thousands of lives of good people have
been lost
in unnecessary War
now the problem with that was you had
largely American journalists but also
British and Australian journalists and I
can't myself in this as well I was
involved in doing some of these stories
you know we credulously accepted the
assurances that the Americans were
giving that there were weapons of mass
destruction in the Iraqi desert and that
there had to be an engagement with
Saddam Hussein to bring this to a
resolution to stop this evil man from
doing these terrible things
the reality was that it soon emerged
within a few weeks of the invasion that
there weren't these wmds the whole
pretext for the war was wrong the
intelligence was wrong
so you have a double standard here you
have the media back in 2003 what's that
18 years ago credulously accepting a
assurances from the national assure
security establishment but oh yeah we
should believe our sources yeah yeah we
should go to war in the Middle East
absolutely
now we've got a situation where a highly
reputable credible intelligence Source
somebody who personally hand delivered
the presidential daily briefings from
the national geospatial agency directly
to the West Wing of the White House
entrusted with 2 000 special access
programs goes public and makes very
dramatic and yeah I'm sure quite
ontologically shocking claims about an
nhi presence an alien presence on this
planet
and how many stories have you seen in
the news sections of the new New York
Times The Washington Post or any of the
TV networks ABC CBS NBC
not one the only stories that have run
in the New York Times or the Washington
Post are doubting op-ed pieces run by
opinion writers that are very easily
marginalized
Ross coldheart wants to make this
information and Technology public so
that we can use it for Humanity's
benefit think of how it could transform
entire Industries even providing an
instant and desperate needed boost for
the global economy especially after
people lost over 36 trillion dollars
last year more than the GDP of the U.S
China and Japan combined still every day
people have seen exceptional results in
the midst of that turmoil thanks to
Masterworks art investing platform who
have had every single exit to date
deliver a positive return to investors
we're talking an awe-inspiring 740
000 plus users over 750 million invested
in more than 225 SEC qualified offerings
they've sold 13 paintings so far with
five of those sales happening just since
we talked about them last in December
now I hear you Kurt I'm no artificiano
all is it truly that simple well
Masterworks breaks these paintings into
shares through a well architected
process with the SEC and if they're
selling a painting you're invested in
you get a share of the profits feel the
brush Strokes of Fortune as three of
their recent sales have painted the
canvas with 10 13 and 35 net returns now
here's the thing Masterworks has a wait
list however because you're a theories
of everything listener you get to
Quantum Leap over the wait list just
click the link in the description if
you'd like to learn about the topics in
this video then a great place to start
would be brilliant brilliant has courses
on gravitational physics electricity and
magnetism Quantum objects even quantum
mechanics with Sabine hosenfelder it's a
place where even if you're entirely new
to a subject you can come to understand
via bite-sized Interactive Learning
experiences these esoteric topics that
underlie modern physics on the theories
of everything Channel there's plenty of
technical talk on extended supersymmetry
and simplectic geometry which underlies
some attempts to unify gravity with
other interactions also soon to come
space-time metric engineering symmetric
teleparallel gravity turns Simon
modifications to general relativity and
a great place to ascertain the
fundamentals of what was just said is
brilliant they even have courses on
neural Nets and statistics and sampling
often when I want to learn about a
subject I'll take courses even on those
I feel like I've mastered only for
brilliant to show me new ways of
thinking about it this happened with
their course on knowledge and
uncertainty where information theory is
taught in intuitive ways of thinking
about the definition of entropy are
shown to you it's fruitful for me to
know where certain unification attempts
with gravity work and don't work and
Brilliant is a great place for me to
patch up gaps in my knowledge helping me
conduct better podcasts and make more
informed assessments visit brilliant.org
toe that's toe for 20 off your annual
premium subscription as usual I
recommend you don't stop before four
lessons you just have to get wet you
have to try it out and I think you'll be
greatly surprised at the ease of which
you can now comprehend subjects you
previously had a difficult time grocking
the only stories that have run in the
New York Times or the Washington Post
are doubting op-ed pieces run by opinion
writers that are very easily
marginalized
why is it that on the one hand 18 years
ago these same National Security
reporters were so credulously willing to
accept and to Parrot the assertions of
intelligence officials that oh yes that
we do have high evidence strong evidence
to support a war in the Middle East
and now 18 years later yet again they're
critical faculties are under test
why are they accepting what I assume is
going on behind the scenes which is
background briefings from people in
Pentagon PR saying oh no no this is all
nonsense you know don't believe this guy
he's got an extra grind or whatever it
is they're saying about David grush
the reality is if they had dirt on David
grush they would have played Dirty by
now they would have dumped it
and for all of the snide capping that
you've read on social media I have not
seen any credible refutation
drawing any reasonable doubt about why
David grush should not be allowed to say
what he's saying yes he hasn't put up
the evidence that he can't put up
because it's classified but why on Earth
did the defense office of
pre-publication Security review give him
the authorization to talk about
non-human intelligence
about crash retrievals about agreements
why did he do that
he did that because he believes on the
basis of evidence he has received he
thinks the American public and the world
have the right to know the truth
and frankly if we are going to continue
with the incredible lack of curiosity
inside the mainstream media where not
one news reporter has engaged with this
issue in a serious way they've all just
ignored it they've gone oh my God I
can't talk about that because if I talk
about that I won't get invited to the
next Pentagon press briefing where I get
told about say the The Latest Scoop
Defector story or the the you know this
is how it works Chomsky talked about
this in manufacturing consent as well
for the Vietnam War but it's not just
the UFO topic like you mentioned it's
the Iraq War as well it's something
that's known about yeah and look it's a
really important one because
it's part of David grush's allegations
and they are only allegations he's been
at Payne's to say yeah sure I've got the
evidence if you want the evidence put me
under oath in the right circumstances
where I'm allowed to give that evidence
and I will provide it but he's not about
to put himself in jail by revealing what
he knows in a public forum because the
Pentagon knows that they have him
where they want him if he reveals beyond
what he's authorized to reveal in the
so-called dopsa the defense office
pre-publication Security review document
if he goes beyond that document he's in
jail in a Flash for breaching his
classified constraints
so you have a really widget I really
think people need to particularly
opinion leaders particularly thought
leaders in politics social media
we're now in a situation where the
Congress I know because I've been
talking to people in the Congress has
actively interviewed and deposed
Witnesses whose support Russia's claims
that's why this legislation that Douglas
Dean Johnson has written about today is
so significant why would the Congress be
talking about companies that are holding
secretly
items of non-earth origin or exotic UAP
material if they didn't think there was
something to it
the people behind this move gillibrand
Marco Rubio it's not unreasonable to
expect that they have presidential
Ambitions one day would they really put
their presidential Ambitions on the line
by making assertions implicit in
legislation like this if they didn't
think there was something to it and what
on Earth is going on inside the major
newspapers in America Canada the UK
Australia that this issue is just
consistently ignored and swept under the
carpet yeah I mean we didn't go when I
was approached by David and it was
suggested that I do this TV interview I
didn't even consider going to ABC CBS or
NBC you know why because because I knew
we wouldn't have got within QE of
getting it on air
and the reason why is because all of
these networks all of these major
newspapers have completely lost the
objectivity on National Security issues
you know it's really interesting one of
the things I've noticed just in the last
few hours while this whole pragosan
Advance on Moscow has been going on the
best commentary has not been coming from
the New York Times or the Washington
Post because all of these institutions
they no longer have the resources to
have their reporters on the ground doing
the work that these kind of papers used
to do they're waiting for the Pentagon
to tell them what to say
and that's the tragedy so I've been
going on to telegram I've been going on
to the sites where you actually have
Russian observers Ukrainian observers on
the ground reporting directly what's
really going on and this is why social
media I think in the long run will be
the entity that breaks the story of the
UAP reality because mainstream Legacy
Media of which I've been apart for so
many years has completely dropped the
ball on the UAP issue that's the problem
and it's a it's a huge dilemma because I
I suspect that there are people in the
Pentagon right now who feel that they've
done a really good job suppressing this
story
that David grush has been effectively
marginalized
and they're working I'm sure behind the
scenes right now to try and neuter any
Congressional inquiries
I mean for example Timber chip the
Tennessee representative
um and um coma the chairman of the
oversight Committee of mahas they've
volunteered that they want a hearing
they want an investigative hearing by
the oversight committee into Dave
grush's allegations and they've made it
quite clear they'd like to call Rush
but there's no way they have the
clearances to hear what David grush
wants to tell them
it's pointless I mean I I have huge
respect for their motivations and and
what they're trying to achieve but even
if they do it in camera it's not
entirely clear to me that all of the
members of the oversight committee that
would want to hear this evidence have
the title 10 title 50 clearances that
would allow them to hear what has been
so well locked up by the National
Security establishment behind special
access programs for so many years and
people are missing the point here
everywhere you go on this story The
pentagon's there ahead of you and I'm
not painting some evil picture there are
really good people in the Pentagon that
I respect and admire good people in the
intelligence Community who are extremely
well motivated and who want this story
out they are as frustrated as we all are
with the fact that there's a lot of
nonsense being used to disguise and hide
what the Pentagon and the government
really knows
but unfortunately there are a Quadra of
people who I suspect are frightened of
being held responsible for the
consequences of their actions who have
presided over what I suspect is a long
and enduring cover-up for decades and
it's quite astonishing because in my
line of work as a journalist you always
get taught to assume a screw-up before a
conspiracy very rarely do conspiracies
happen largely because governments can't
keep secrets but in this case they have
kept this secret they've done an
incredible job and when it's leaked
they've been able to marginalize
ridicule and stigmatize the people
who've come forward
because people say oh it's never leaked
you know therefore it can't be true it
has leaked
people have come forward
but what the National Security
establishment has done so well through
operatives of disinformation who
continue to get traction to my huge
frustration even on social media today
and I'm not going to name them but there
are people that consistently appear on
social media and plant false information
who purport to be representing
government agencies and they're not all
they are are shills of disinformation
and they're there to essentially
continue to sow doubt about the issue
it's brilliant I take my head off to
them they've done a fantastic job
but I can tell you the Congress or there
are individuals in the Congress who are
determined to get to the bottom of this
and this legislation this bill that
Senator gillibrand has now brought to
the house or is about to bring to the
house is incredibly important it's
vitally important that this legislation
pass because it's only a bill at this
time do you think it will it's a tough
gig I mean okay it's a bipartisan
measure uh both sides of the Senate
Select Committee for intelligence want
this bill to pass
Marco Rubio's for it as well
um
uh I think ultimately what it boils down
to is whether there is the political
will in the Congress and the political
will is derived from public sentiment
and at the moment you know I I would say
that because of the control that the
mainstream media has even to this day on
social opinion public opinion
I I would say it's a line ball at the
moment whether or not the Congress is
going to back it and and certainly
I think there probably will be private
in camera secret Congressional hearings
like there already have been because I
mean what we're talking about here it's
already known Marco Rubio senator
gillibrand they already know what I know
they already know about the Legacy
program and the reverse engineering
program because there have been
um depositions of witnesses plural who
have provided evidence to their
committees to support the claims made by
David grush and people missed this point
secretly inside the Congress now for
quite some time many many months there
have been hearings where Witnesses have
come forward
and I'm told at least one of those
hearings Jake Sullivan the National
Security adviser for the president may
very well have been involved
why the White House Press Corps not
asking questions like this did you see
that ridiculous
um question and answer with um forgive
me if I've got her name um is it Corrine
Jean-Pierre the presidential spokeswoman
lovely woman but she was asked the other
day about the claims made by Mr grush
and she just deferred it she just ducked
past it to the Pentagon and said you'll
have to ask the Pentagon about that
why is it satisfactory for the White
House Press Corps supposedly the elite
of media in the world to allow the
presidential spokesperson to duck a
question that is absolutely fundamental
when a very senior intelligence
operative recently resigned has come
forward saying all these incredible
things
they may well be incredible they may
very well be ontologically shocking to
people
but why is the media not doing its job
and asking the question why did the
White House Press Corps when that
question was asked just let the
presidential spokeswoman duck it and say
oh you'll have to ask the Pentagon about
that because what the Pentagon then does
is it says Arrow which is the pentagon's
UFO investigation office has no credible
evidence to support you know the
existence of extraterrestrial presence
on planet Earth or something like that
and that's not an answer
the Pentagon is confining its answers to
Arrow and arrow is heavily constrained
in where it's allowed to look and what
it's allowed to do because it doesn't
have the security clearances it needs to
make the investigations it needs to be
able to do into special access programs
that are concealing allegedly these
hidden programs
and so you've got this you've got this
um catch-all where the public is being
fed aligned and where you see you know
columns like this in my national
newspaper which are just spurious
nonsense where they they essentially
without any justification they make a
claim that it's all a conspiracy theory
and they don't look at the fact that the
Pentagon is saying gee we think this is
serious enough to put in legislation
reference to technology of non-earth
origin
G as journalists maybe we should ask the
question why is the Pentagon being asked
or why a private Aerospace being asked
to reveal if they have items of
non-earth origin if there's nothing to
this
is it why is it good enough I mean
do you get the feeling I feel like I'm
saying the same thing over and over
again because I do I mean I I don't know
what has happened to the capacity for
critical thinking that used to be in the
American Media I know
I mean what happened to the Brave and
Resolute congressmen and women who would
ask tough questions the Daniel inuese
the you know the the the
um Harry Reids you know the people who
would actually stand up and question
are we to accept that now congress's
role is to meekly rubber stamp what the
Pentagon and the intelligence Community
say
because we're being played here even
even this legislation
that is coming up uh in the gillibrand
bill
um it's very constrained in what it
allows
the
um
well in what it requires these companies
to do
under my reading of this legislation
if the Aerospace company was privately
involved in the recovery of non-human
technology if it didn't use the US
government to recover that technology
it doesn't have to report it to Arrow it
doesn't have to report it to Congress
and I'm told that on multiple occasions
private aerospace companies using
military
private military contractors have been
involved in Crash retrievals and you
know I can hear the debunkers and the
declaimers going and rolling their eyes
and going wacky conspiracy theory I
don't care what you guys think I know
what my sources are telling me and my
sources are telling me that private
aerospace companies have been involved
in private retrievals and under the
Senate intelligence committee proposed
legislation I don't think there would be
an obligation on those private
aeros-based companies to reveal what
they have
another loophole in this legislation
that's a worry to me is that if a
private Aerospace company is in
possession of technology that was
recovered with government assistance or
with you know passed on to them by
government say 50 60 70 years ago
if they divest themselves of that
technology
then they're not required and in my
reading of this bill to report it to the
Congress or to the arrow what do you
mean if they divest themselves of the
technology okay well I understand at the
moment I'll tell you my understanding
this is how much I know I am told that
right at this very moment there is a
major private Aerospace company that is
trying to divest itself of
a craft
it has approached another company
expressing interest in selling that
technology to them
and the reason why
I suspect it's because they've known
this legislation is coming
that's what's going on here
you know you have private aerospace
companies that are actively involved in
trying to subvert the intention of
Congress
now roll your eyes I don't care the
simple fact is there are people who are
telling me this from within the
the Legacy program who are very
concerned that there is an active
attempt underway to hide technology from
the Congress
and there's another issue here another
issue is
if a private Aerospace company has been
involved in a retrieval as I understand
they have been
by law
it's their property
sure they may have to reveal it to the
Congress but by law there's a very very
good argument that they are under no
obligation to reveal
uh sorry to hand over that technology or
to give the knowledge to the government
and that's because
there's actually a law called the law
and ownership and the law of ownership
and control of meteorites
and essentially um
there are Provisions in international
law that mean that um uh it's not just
meteorites essentially um uh
if you come into possession of something
and
you've spent the money on recovering it
yourself it's an incentive for people to
develop the technology that might arise
from that recovery that they enjoy the
private ownership of that material
so one of the issues that we have behind
all of this is let's assume
hypothetically that there are private
aerospace companies that have been
sitting on technology for 50 60 70 years
in the first category let's say Roswell
happened in 1947 and let's say around
about 1950 or so or perhaps in the 1970s
the Roswell craft was passed on to a
private Aerospace company
what happens then if they've had
possession of that object for 50 60
years
does the US government really have a
claim on that technology
in law there's a question mark
and what if as I noticed somebody was
recently asserting just in the last 24
hours on Twitter what if say technology
from recoveries in the US
has been moved extraterially into Canada
oh gee that's interesting what if Canada
was secretly in possession of retrieved
technology that is owned by a U.S
Aerospace company and being worked on by
oh say Canadian government scientists in
collaboration with U.S scientists
what's the law on that
does the U.S Congress have extratorial
control over that technology interesting
question
and then separately from that another
truck hole a loophole that you could
drive a truck through here is what if
those um what if those private aerospace
companies have recovered that technology
using private military contractors as I
understand it has very much been the
case in the last few years
what if it's been entirely recovered by
those private aerospace companies
perhaps in collaboration with the US
government but they've spent all the
money and all the resources on doing
that shouldn't they ought properly to
have the rights to that technology
I mean imagine hypothetically if it is
true imagine just imagine if it is true
that say um
Lockheed Martin let's say Lockheed
Martin has a spacecraft
let's say they've got a a perfectly
operating flying saucer from say I don't
know Kingman Texas sitting on blocks
somewhere in a cave sitting in a private
facility somewhere
why do they have to give that technology
knowledge to the Congress and why should
they
they're a private Aerospace company
they've got they've got every reason to
want to develop an advantage over their
um over their corporate Rivals even if
that company was dealing with the
government
well that's the issue the issue is I've
spoken to people at a very high level in
Silicon Valley who have resources and
money who are very angry that they
believe
technology was gifted vested into
private aerospace companies 50 60 years
ago when they didn't exist
and then are aware of this and what
they're not what they're not angry about
is that the public don't know about it
what they're angry about is that they've
not been cut into it that's what's going
on here
and it may all sound like a wacky
conspiracy theory but let's see it
investigated
Rush has made these claims he has risked
his career he's risked his security
classification to come forward and give
evidence and he's done it by the book he
still has those security classifications
he does okay can I summarize the grush
story and see if I have it correct sure
so grush is a senior official he has was
was a senior official has or had plenty
of access to different secret parts of
the government secret activities I'm
trying to make this simple for myself
and the audience as well he's like okay
I'm seeing something here that has to do
with non-human intelligence I'm hearing
it Through the Grapevine I perhaps have
seen doc no no it's more it's it's more
than Through the Grapevine he's spoken
directly he's spoken directly with
people in the Legacy program or people
who at least purport to have had Direct
knowledge and contact with non-human
technology okay then he's like people
namely the public should know about this
okay how do I go about doing this
because I don't want to go to jail so
I'm going to go to a part of the
government there's a part of the
government called dopser so defense
defense office of pre-publication
Security review it's when somebody's got
a security clearance they need to get
authorization to speak publicly about
whatever it is they want to speak about
they write down in a proposal what they
want to say and then dopsa approves it
and that's exactly what he's done here
he's gone to dobsa the defense office
pre-publication Security review office
and they have approved him
revealing what he's revealed okay so
then he tells them here's what I want to
tell the public and then they say yes or
no but the parts they say yes to sure
and just to be just to be clear-cut the
fact that dobster gives that approval is
not an endorsement that what he is
saying is necessarily true all it is is
merely an endorsement that what he is
saying is not breaching National
Security because that's their role their
role is to make sure that the the
um the statements that he makes don't
breach his security classification okay
so they're not saying that it's true
they're just saying that what you're
saying is not classified okay so then he
goes on with you and this huge new story
breaks and he says that there are
non-human intelligences or non-human
crafts and bodies so what I was thinking
is there's this no win scenario here
because if he says extraordinary claims
then we can just say yeah but the
government said that that's not
classified if that was going on that
would be classified they would say
please don't talk about that well that's
what's going through my head and plenty
of others so how do you think about that
okay I mean I think he had to get doctor
approval in order to do the interview
that he did with myself and that he did
with Leslie Kane and Ralph Blumenthal
and he did that and as I've emphasized
that approval in and of itself doesn't
mean it's a warranty by the defense
department that what he's saying is true
but if the defense department had not
wanted him to do the interview then they
would have had to have cited the laws
that he was breaching by revealing what
he knows and then as he's explained it
to me to to be forced to he would have
taken them on in court and challenged
them on that and he was ready to do that
because
if as he asserts there is illegal and
possibly criminal withholding of
evidence from the Congress
that legal challenge would have given
him the right to present evidence
that would then have validated his
claims publicly in a way that would have
been incontrovertible for the defense
department
so the only choice that they had when
presented with the doctor allegation at
the doctor application
was to give him the approval because
they couldn't risk
if he's telling the truth they couldn't
risk the damage that would be caused if
they try to cover this up of this being
forced out into the open in an open
Hearing in a court
because there are lawyers who are
prepared to take this to the highest
courts in the land
there are people in
companies in America who are angry that
they have been cut out of the vesting of
technology that allegedly occurred 50 60
years ago and there is bitterness that a
small Cadre of private aerospace
companies in the military intelligence
Community with a long association with
the U.S government have been given
alleged access to this technology in a
way that other companies haven't not
least because those companies feel they
have a better job a better capacity of
developing the Technologies than the
private aerospace companies that have
been trying to do it for 50 or 60 years
that's what's behind all of this it's
not really a public campaign
what's driving the moves in Congress is
that privately there are companies that
are bitterly angry that they have been
cut out of the loop
it's part of American capitalism free
enterprise good old free enterprise that
companies should be able to compete for
contracts with you know to help the
American government do what it does well
if it's true that there are companies
that have been given access to non-human
alien technology and that they've had
that technology now for 60 70 80 years
if that's true and that's what Mr grush
is alleging
true
then there are other companies in Us in
America that have every right to feel
resentful and bitter that they've been
cut out of the deal it might explain the
reason for some of the dominant
companies in in defense Aerospace today
this is what's at stake here and so
what's going on behind the scenes is yes
there is a formidable military and
intelligence Lobby trying to shut this
whole grush stuff done trying to stop
the Senate intelligence committee from
holding public hearings and it's the
Senate intelligence committee by the way
that has the security appearances that
would allow it to hear the evidence that
Mr grush has got
but what's going on behind the scenes is
quietly and behind the scenes there are
other people
who are not part of that defense
Aerospace Loop who are bitterly angry
and they are lobbying their congressmen
as well and they're saying if this is
true and I think it is because I've had
conversations with some of these people
if this is true this is outrageous this
is an abrogation of the good qualities
of American capitalism and free
enterprise why should these private
aerospace companies be given a free run
hence this groundbreaking legislation
which for once and for all is going to
force the truth to come to the open if
it's true that there is non-human
technology of non-earth origin held by
private aerospace companies somewhere in
the world
under this law that's proposed they will
now be forced to reveal it that's why
this matters
but as a separate issue I don't know
necessarily that the public is going to
get told this
I think that there is quite a a strong
opinion inside the Congress even amongst
some of the people pushing for
disclosure
that if we can get away with revealing
this to the Congress privately in
oversight committees inside secure
compartmented information a secret you
know compartmented information
facilities or whatever the word is for a
skiff
um
it might be the better way to do it
I don't think there is a push or a
strong feeling in the Congress
politically that it's a good idea for
America to know if it's true that there
are non-human intelligences engaging
with this planet
I don't think that there is a strong
political impetus for the politicians to
feel that it's time for the existence of
the retention of non-human technology to
be brought to public attention
but I do feel and this is what people
need to understand there is an
imperative inside the Congress now for
the truth to be brought to the attention
of those oversight committees and it's
what those oversight committees decide
to do with that information that will be
absolutely fundamental I mean no
disrespect to I think Mark Warner who's
the chairman of the Senate Select
Committee for intelligence but he's I
think based in Virginia I mean who are
his constituency in Virginia the
military and intelligence Community what
does the military and intelligence
Community likely want done about some
Revelations of retained highly advanced
technology well if I was them if I was
the CIA the NSA the DIA I'd want it kept
confidential so that we can develop it
for our own advantage and try and
develop a superiority over the Russians
or the Chinese
it's not hard I wouldn't want it made
public and I'd be lobbying the chairman
of the Senate Select Committee for
intelligence to keep it confidential
but I think that what's slowly happening
is people misunderstand and I think
there's a large amount of the social
media commentary at the moment on uaps
who think that what we're heading
towards is some Mass disclosure event I
don't think that's going to happen I
really don't
I think that what is probably going to
be happening is that a very controlled
disclosure behind the scenes in Secure
facilities inside the Congress where for
the first time congressional committees
are actually brought up to speed with
what's really going on and I think they
will learn that yes there is retrieved
non-human technology and that there is a
secret reverse engineering program going
on in which Your Country Canada is
involved intimately and if people dug
into that they'd find a whole lot more
if they only bothered to ask don't you
find it by the way extraordinary Kurt
absolutely extraordinary that this Larry
McGuire letter can leak Jeremy Corbell
and net leaked this letter I've known
about this letter for some time and in
fact it was posted back in May by
another source on Twitter and it was
completely ignored by people Daniel
Lotus a very respectable journalist from
Canada yeah yeah has noted that this
document was actually up online as early
as May
but it actually says Larry McGuire
alleges to the minister of National
Defense in Canada quote you may not be
aware defense research and development
Canada
drdc that's Canada's equivalent if you
like of dapa the defense Advanced
research projects agency has
participated in efforts to analyze UAP
which is publicly traceable to Circa
1950.
this recovered foreign material is
studied through the five eyes foreign
material program the FMP which in Canada
is sponsored by the Canadian Forces
intelligence command aligned with
several intelligence sharing
arrangements and treaties
now McGuire who's not a senior Member of
Parliament but he's obviously spoken and
I know he has he's spoken to people
inside that program I know he's spoken
to scientists and people with a direct
knowledge of that retrieval program
but what's not happening is the spin is
starting people are now coming back and
saying oh the only thing he knows is
stuff that Grant Cameron's told him from
public sources that's not true and Mr
McGuire needs to be pushed and a good
journalist in Canada needs to get on the
phone to Mr guy or stick a TV Camera in
front of him and say to him sir what are
you alleging when you told your defense
minister that drdc has been working in
efforts to analyze UAP what is your
knowledge based on is it just based on
what you've written somebody else's book
or is it based on Direct conversations
with sources
and I think he will tell you the latter
Larry McGuire if you're watching I would
love to have you on if you're willing to
answer questions like this
now what worries me is that we're not
seeing the follow-up from media I'm
trained as an investigative journalist
to ask questions like that because I've
learned to read between the lines in
what arrows is so when Susan Goff the
Pentagon PR woman stands up and says
that Arrow has found no credible
evidence of E.T
that sounds like a pentagon denial but
it's not because she's speaking for
Arrow which is not a body in the
Pentagon that has the clearances to even
ask the questions that need to be asked
and so we've got this ridiculous
um containment going on of information
where
adlib accepting credulous media in the
mainstream media is allowing a continued
peddling of falsehood
and
people like myself who are engaging
directly with people in the program who
are watching to see what happens and
weighing whether to come forward I'm
getting increasingly pessimistic because
whilst legislation like this this bill
is important
you could drive a truck through the
loopholes in it and as I've pointed out
you know as I've pointed out you know a
clever lawyer for a big defense
zerospace company could go look all we
need to do is develop a front company
divest it into that front company and we
no longer have physical position of that
information so let's let's just do that
I mean there is any number of ways they
can evade accountability to the Congress
what is needed and what I suspect is not
going to happen is the kind of proactive
investigation that David grushed it
because this is the issue
um in the uh comments that were made by
Susan Goff the Pentagon PR woman
she said there is no restriction to
Arrow the pentagon's UFO investigation
office receiving that's the important
Point receiving any past or present UAP
related information regardless of the
affiliation of the original
classification Authority within DOD or
the intelligence community and receiving
is the pertinent word because arrow is
set up to receive information that
Witnesses decide to come forward with to
Arrow under the incentive Provisions
laid out in the National Defense
authorization Act and I can tell you
because I'm talking to some of them
those Witnesses are sitting there
looking at Arrow and they do not think
that arrow is an objective player they
think that there is spin coming from the
Pentagon that it's being disingenuous
with what it's saying and they do not
trust Arrow or its heads people like Dr
Sean Kirkpatrick however well-motivated
he may be the perception is that arrow
is not a fair player which is why David
grush went directly to Congress by the
way because before the National Defense
authorization act legislation was
brought in in late December last year
he'd already given his evidence to the
oversight committees in the Congress I
suspect he would now be required to go
to Arrow first under the new legislation
and he probably wouldn't do that because
he doesn't trust them because he's seen
how they operate
and the point is is that when I drew
your attention then to the fact that
Susan goff's comment was restricted to
Arrow receiving any past or present UAP
related information
whole response is predicated on the
assumption that people are going to come
forward
what David grush did was proactively go
out and do his job as a UAP task force
investigator and he investigated and
that's what wrong footed the Pentagon
because there are I'm sorry it's it's a
terrible thing to have to say but there
are people in your military and
intelligence community in America who
are actively involved in a cover-up and
I include Canada in that as well there
are people in both governments that do
not want the story of Crash retrievals
and reverse engineering programs to come
out and I think a large part of that is
because they're worried about the
consequences for them and their careers
if it's revealed that they've been
actively subverting accountability to
Congress
and
so what David grush did was rather than
wait for witnesses to come forward to
Arrow as came forward came through in
the ndia legislation at the time he was
working on the UAP task force he was
tasked to go out and proactively
investigate and that's what he did he
went out and he proactively investigated
he talked to some of his friends who had
similar security clearances to his and
as he told me in the interview to his
shock and amazement he discovered that
some of them knew about the program The
Legacy program
and contemporaneously with Mr grush the
reason he and I crossed paths is because
even though neither Rivers have
confirmed this to the other because we
don't want to betray sources we suspect
that at different times we were talking
to some of the same people inside the
program interesting and so I was told
about the existence of this guy David
Rush who was doing this great work doing
this proactive investigation and how he
was the victim of reprisals
reprisals I can't go into a lot of
detail but they formed the basis of his
complaint to the Inspector General both
of the defense department and the
intelligence community
but um I I think
it's for Mystic rush to give evidence
under oath in the Congress and in the
public hearing that might be happening
where he can describe what's been
happening
I'm waiting for him to have the right to
explain to the public what's been going
on but frankly I mean I know from other
Witnesses what's been going on is quite
despicable I've spoken to other
Witnesses who tell me that they've been
threatened
they've been told there or their
families could be killed if they spoke
publicly or came forward with the
evidence that they have there is a very
active attempt to try to subvert the
congress's intentions in forcing this to
be made
knowledge to the public or at least to
the congress's attention I mean what
people need to understand Kurt is the
Congress already knows there are members
particularly of the gang of eight not
all of the Congress some members of the
Congress are members of the Congress no
no no no no some members of the Congress
only a very few select members of the
Congress have the clearances that are
sufficient to allow them to even hear
this information
sometimes when David Rush was giving
evidence I've heard from people who are
in the room
certain people had to leave the room
because they didn't have a sufficiently
high clearance to hear what he was
revealing that's in this oversight
committee that you're referring to yeah
okay and do you happen to know if that's
split politically is even of those who
have access or those who are in the know
or is it more Democrats than
conservatives or vice versa it's
interesting actually I I'd say there's a
bipartisan View at the moment that that
this is something that ought properly to
be brought to the attention of the
Congress
I wouldn't say that there's a bipartisan
View at the moment that this ought to be
made public okay
um and I think people are missing this
point
um the the motivation of good men like
Christopher Mellon Louis zondo and the
people who've done the right thing in
trying to bring this attention to the
Congress
is a large part of the emotivation is to
make sure that proper accountability
controls are put in place and that if
there have been
breaches of the law or crimes committed
that those crimes and breaches of the
law are investigated and that any people
responsible are properly dealt with
according to law
but whether it's decided in the
interests of National Security that this
be brought to public attention is
another question entirely
now we know I think it's a reasonable
assumption that back in 2016 at the time
of the Clinton Trump election campaign
it's very very clear now that there was
a an effort
inside the Pentagon to address the fact
that Hillary Clinton was going to be
clearly a disclosure president
she and her husband Bill know something
clearly and they were clearly according
to the leaked Wikileaks emails of the
John pedister emails
podesta as the um I think he was the
campaign chairman for Hillary Clinton
was deeply involved in negotiations with
two senior former Pentagon Generals in
discussing disclosure UAP disclosure
and clearly this was being driven I
suspect out of a realization that with a
president that was determined to push
for disclosure
there was going to have to be some
Candor from the defense and intelligence
establishment
what's happened since is
in the intervening seven what is it how
many years is it six five years in the
intervening five years there's been I
think a strong pushback from the
intelligence and defense Community
they're really angry and nervous about
the fact that this might be revealed
because there is I mean I'm very
confident there is a crash retrieval
program underway where there is
attempted reverse engineering on Craft
my source Nat cut that's the former
director of science technology and
development for the U.S Navy he told me
that and I I put that in my book and he
went on to introduce me to people in the
Legacy program who confirmed the
veracity of what he said now the simple
fact is that um
I don't think there's the political will
at the moment for
this to be made public I don't think
you're going to see what a lot of people
in ufology dream of which is the
president standing up at a lectern and
saying ladies and Gentlemen We Are Not
Alone
uh I don't think the world is ready for
that at the moment or at least that's
the view of the Pentagon and the
intelligence community and I think it
frankly suits strategic objectives of
the United States to maintain National
Security dominance that it keeps the
fact of recovered technology
confidential
and I do think there's a strong
likelihood if not probability that this
will all be put back in a box that there
will be quietly
changes made at a very high level in
Congress to ensure that um the gang of
eight at least is briefed properly about
this the gang of eight is a group of um
I think it's nine very senior members of
Congress who are selected because of
their seniority to be briefed into the
most sensitive secrets in the US
government
and um I wouldn't be surprised at all if
the decision was made that yes we admit
the existence of this program to that
committee and we um we uh keep it all
off the books for now because this is
extraordinarily sensitive that gang of
eight is known like it's known who they
are yeah the gang of eight is known like
their names oh yeah you know it's known
it's it's it's it's referred to sorry
it's gang of age
um it's it's well known as the primary
oversight body on intelligence issues
inside the Congress and it's cleared to
supposedly hear the most intimate and
secrets of all inside the US Military
and intelligence establishment and
what's been happening allegedly is that
they have not been briefed into what you
and I are discussing
individuals on the gang of eight I
suspect no no some of what we're talking
about
but I think that what's happened is
there was a divesting of this technology
as early as the 1950s and more
lately in the 1970s under Nixon
and because it's been held for 50 or 60
years in private Aerospace it's been
very ambiguous whether there is even an
obligation to disclose the Congress
knowledge of this
and I think it's suited everybody to
keep it quiet to keep it in private
Aerospace but as people like Dr Eric
Davis have said publicly I think he said
this to Alejandro Rojas on a podcast a
few years ago he said that in 1989
the the reverse engineering program was
actually shut down for a while basically
because it wasn't getting anywhere that
it was suffering from lack of funding
and that's tragic and this is one of the
reasons why there is a frustration from
inside that Legacy program that if it's
time the Congress knew and frankly they
think the public should know because you
know if these Technologies are real
just just for a moment Abandon All
disbelief and go if these Technologies
are real
if it is true that there are craft that
can do what Elizondo has referred to as
the five observables you know positive
lift propulsion systems you know
instantaneous velocity uh incredible you
know speeds even superluminal speeds
um uh transmedium travel and stealth
mode if those Technologies exist
it means that someone
has developed technologies that are far
beyond known human technology
and the interesting thing is we are I
suspect at that point at the moment
where even the head of the all domain
anomaly resolution office Dr Sean
Kirkpatrick has admitted that there are
anomalous metallic spheres witnessed by
military and other observers around the
planet for some time now that are doing
anomalous things and Witnesses describe
them as apparently moving under
intelligent control
something is allowing these objects that
do not have any visible propulsion
system to do things that we cannot
explain it suggests that there is
technology there Energy Systems there
technological secrets that
are or inspiring
and and for example I mean one of the
great crises that our planet faces at
the moment is the risk of global warming
the climate change imagine if overnight
that Energy System behind this
technology could be used and derived to
assist Humanity to a clean source of
energy
if that exists and it does appear that
it does exist otherwise what's
propelling these objects that even the
arrow admits are real
this is the thing that I find there's a
logical dissonance there's a dissonance
between what we now know publicly which
is yes uaps are real yes we are seeing
anomalous objects that we cannot explain
that appear to be displaying the five
observables yes this is real
by implication they are using a
technology we do not understand they
must have enormous capacities for
extracting energy in a way that we do
not understand and they obviously have
propulsion systems that are not emitting
Heat
or displaying a propeller or a
propulsion system that we're familiar
with
by any definition the fact that we've
admitted that such a phenomenon is real
is mind-boggling because it means
someone out there is capable of doing
this
and what I find perplexing is the utter
lack of curiosity
you know at what stage does because I'm
hearing even from within NASA and even
inside the US government I'm hearing
from people who work for organizations
that take an avowedly skeptical view
organizations like NASA for example that
taken invalidly skeptical view on all of
this phenomenon and privately they're
admitting to me yeah this is real you
know it's it's baffling to us as well
and they are as intrigued as I am by the
fact that there is this dissonance
between what we know
I mean look at the facts make your own
judgment
we are looking at objects that are
displaying the capabilities of the
so-called five observables right
including capacities to draw
extraordinary amounts of energy and
propulsion systems without any visible
means of propulsion no heat I mean how
on Earth does an object like a metallic
ball stay aloft without
rocket propulsion or propellers
how is it doing that perhaps one
explanation is that it's developed some
form of anti-gravity propulsion now if
such a technology exists and frankly
prima facie it appears to
on the US government's own admission
these objects are anomalous they can't
explain them if these objects exist as
they appear to
someone is sitting on that technology
at what point does the world develop
sufficient curiosity to compel those who
know about it to come forward and admit
what they know
and that's all Mr grush is asking he's
never expected that people would believe
him just on what he said to me in the
interview or is it in his interview with
Leslie Kane and Ralph Blumenthal what
he's pleaded for as a loyal patriotic
American citizen who's played it
completely by the book he's done the
doctor he sought permission to speak
he's obtained it he's kept within his
security oath and made sure he doesn't
transgress that security oath in
revealing what he reveals to me or to
Leslie and to Ralph but what he said is
I am a credible former senior
intelligence officer
call my bluff if I'm lying I go to jail
I accept that because I will have
perjured myself not only before the
Congress but also before the inspectors
general of defense and intelligence
community
think about that why would a man of such
high credibility and repute come forward
publicly
and put himself at such risk if he's
lying
all he wants is for his claims to be
tested and investigated what what are
people frightened of if it's not true
let's deal with it really quickly
and if it's not true yeah then you know
frankly um articles like this nonsense
article that appeared in the Australian
newspaper just yesterday can can be got
rid of it's the default media ridicule
mode where what they do is they
essentially go oh it can't possibly be
true therefore it isn't
that's been the default mode for decades
and what people don't realize is that
it's part of Russia's allegations that
they've been deliberately disinformed by
the Pentagon and by the intelligence
community that there's been an active
disinformation that frankly our media
and our movies and our TV shows have
been manipulated literally you've had
people from the intelligence and
Military coming in and actually
controlling and dictating by regulating
access to military resources how movies
are told how to explain about that
please
oh sure for example um my co-host of my
podcast uh need to know Bryce is able uh
Bryce is an illustrious Hollywood
screenwriter and producer and he made a
TV series that was very much the
precursor to X-Files called Dark Skies
and in Dark Skies it tells the story of
alien beings secretly operating at the
time of JFK
um infiltrating the US government and
it's it's essentially it's a science
fiction story yeah and he postulates
that JFK was murdered because of his
attempts to bring this out into the open
the fact of a secret alien presence on
planet Earth now that's fiction
and in one of the sequences the aliens
possess humans by quite frighteningly
emitting a ganglion from their mass and
and literally putting it inside a human
being and taking them over and it's
quite frightening and terrifying and
it's one of the graphic video images
that you see on Dark Skies great Bryce
had a lot of fun telling it
but the way he tells it he and his um uh
co-producer colleague were approached by
the department of Navy intelligence
and in secret they were approached and
offered the opportunity to tell the
story accurately about how aliens really
do possess people now they can't verify
the truth of what these guys were
telling them but what both he and Brett
his colleague attested to is that they
were actually approached by a military
agency and offered the opportunity to
collaborate on getting the information
in their fictional series as accurate as
possible
and apparently that's been happening in
Hollywood for years
um they've been collaborations between
the Pentagon the defense department the
intelligence community and Movie Makers
sorry do you put accurate as possible in
quotations because you feel like they're
going to feed them disinformation at
this point I don't know I don't know and
I don't know the truth of it I mean I
don't know if aliens do have such
capacities if aliens exist
but isn't it intriguing why would a
military intelligence agency be wanting
to actively involve itself in in
controlling the output of a fictional TV
show to influence the public about a
non-human intelligence aliens that's
been happening in Hollywood for years
and since Bryce and I spoke about that
on our need to know podcast which people
by the way can access at
www.needtnow.today the link will be on
screen right now as well as in the
description sure but you know since we
spoke about that I've heard from other
people who've told me about how there's
been active attempts by U.S military and
intelligence to essentially influence
how movies are told when it comes to
talking about non-human intelligence for
decades why are they doing that what
what what's the role of the military or
the intelligence community in
influencing fictional stories in
Hollywood
why would they feel the necessity to do
that
I'm just asking that question but again
it's the lack of curiosity by media
because a lot of this has been dismissed
as tinfoil had nonsense and conspiracy
theories
it's not it really isn't I mean I I know
for a fact I've spoken directly with
producers and filmmakers who've had
these approaches and there are whole
books written about the way out I think
it's one called um I think it's called
Silver sources I recommend it it's a
great read talks about how Hollywood has
routinely been uh meddled with by the
military and intelligence community on
the issue of uaps
can you tell me more about these fears
you said that they're across the Earth
and that they okay they move about of
their own ways
as as viewers of my YouTube channel
which if you just go to YouTube and put
in need to know and cool tart you will
come across documentaries that I've made
for channel 7 Australia
and then one that I made in 2022 I
interviewed a guy in Texas called Jim
marlin who told this credible and and I
I emphasize extraordinarily almost
unbelievable story about this metallic
sphere that he has possession of and how
large are these fears
I'll be good sorry how large are we
speaking of oh the sphere that he had is
sort of you know it's about about that
big
um okay it's I think it's from memory it
was about 40 40 to 50 pounds for those
listening Ross just gestured with his
hands and it's approximately arm's
length so that's two to three feet and
very solid he'd never opened it he'd
never tried to cut it open he didn't
want to cut it open but he claimed that
it was moving under its own control at
times and
um he um
he basically uh uh uh told me this
elaborate story about how he'd got it
from a friend of his who'd literally
seen it fall out of some kind of craft
that hovered over his property
and I I ran the story because I've been
talking to people now for some time
who've been telling me about sightings
of metallic spheres all over the world
and that there is a phenomenon that that
multiple Witnesses have seen where
metallic spheres
operating under apparently their own
propulsion with no visible means of
propulsion are intelligently moving
around airplanes objects in the sky
their video their photographed
and I've also spoken to people in
uh sensitive areas in your government in
the US government uh who've told me that
this is something that needs to be taken
seriously
and what's fascinating is in the most
recent UAP hearing people again again I
just find it amazing how lacking in
curiosity most of the media are
Dr Sean Kirkpatrick the head of Arrow
the all domain anomaly resolution office
the pentagon's UAP investigation office
somewhat begrudgingly admitted that yes
there are anomalous metallics views
doing anomalous things moving in
anomalous ways
that have been seen all over the world
that they cannot explain and a number of
them have been photographed or videoed
by
American Military assets notably in the
Middle East and captured on video or
photographs
and
um it's interesting because since I did
that documentary on uh Channel 7
Australia I have my life has not been my
own I have been swamped with people
sending me videos photographs personal
accounts of seeing these metallic
spheres
um I had one yesterday a guy sent me a a
a
an account of he and his girlfriend
lying in grass in a field somewhere in I
think it was Macedonia and they look up
and there's this metallic sphere
hovering right above their heads and and
you know ultimately
people say witness evidence isn't worth
a job but we send people to prison on
witness evidence you know we convict
people and give them the death sentence
on witness evidence and when you have as
I now have hundreds of people if not
thousands actually hundreds of people
testifying that they have seen these
anomalous metallic spheres doing weird
things
um
I think it should be investigated and so
interestingly begrudgingly the
pentagon's arrow office has admitted it
should be investigated as well
and this is the thing that amuses me is
that everybody in the mainstream media
either ignored or wrote off the most
recent UAP hearing but you actually had
an admission from the head of the
pentagon's UAP investigation office that
yeah there are anomalous things that we
can't explain we have to admit that
these include metallic spheres now one
of the things he didn't explain is how
did he know they were metallic
have they recovered them
I mean I wonder and so what we've done
is um in collaboration with Professor
Gary Nolan
um Jim marlin the Texas owner of at
least one of these spheres uh and I know
owners of other spheres are hopefully
able to collaborate with Professor Nolan
and um he's getting access to a
sophisticated materials analysis
laboratory and we're in our own time
going to do our own analysis
and it'll be interesting to see what
results eventuate and we will report on
those results if and when we can do so
um and I think frankly that's what's got
to happen here because I suspect well I
know that the US government knows a lot
more about these metallics views than
it's prepared to let on
um
uh I I have to be very guarded in what I
say because I have to protect sources
but um
uh suffice to say I I think the public
will get to hear some very interesting
information about those objects in due
course what's the timeline on that
What's the progress look like so far I
don't know
can't comment okay
earlier you mentioned the Legacy program
it's still going on though but it's
called The Legacy program
yeah it's essentially it's a it's an
acknowledgment I guess that this is a
program that goes back to the second
world war at least that there have been
retrievals since allegedly according to
grush
well the first retrieval he knows about
was in 1933 which is allegedly the
magenta Italy Italian
uh UAP Kraft which was allegedly
returned or recovered by the Americans
in 1944 with the assistance of the
Vatican
and brought back to America and
um if that's true that's what Mr
gracious alleging if that's true one can
only hope that it's investigated and
that people get to the bottom of in
collaboration with the Vatican yes the
the Vatican interceded to assist in
handing the technology over from the
vestiges of the Italian government at
the end of the fascist Mussolini regime
and handing it over to the Americans as
the Americans moved into Italy at the
end of the second world war so that
doesn't mean that there's something
inherently Christian about this it just
happened to be where the Vatican is like
there's something geographical about it
do you know it's funny I've spent a
large part of my career revealing the
horrible sorted history of sexual abuse
in the Catholic church so I'm not a fan
of the way it's conducted itself with
its treatment of children but one thing
I will applaud the Catholic Church on is
that it's long had a very Progressive
attitude towards the notion of a
non-human intelligence and I think 10
years ago the Vatican astronomer they do
actually have a Vatican observatory in
Italy uh he spoke publicly about the
notion that essentially whatever species
we are of intelligent being we are all
God's children and I think the Vatican
knows an enormous amount about the
phenomenon and one person I commend you
speak to is Diana Walsh kasoka who's
written a terrific book called American
Cosmic and she's got a new book coming
out that I've been privileged to preview
and it's fascinating I have indeed
spoken with Diana pasulka it's a great
conversation actually it's one of my
favorite conversations on the whole of
theories of everything where we talk
about the dark side of the phenomenon
especially psychologically as well as
how to cope with it it's listed in the
description and it's fascinating and uh
I think the Vatican is well aware of
allegations that the planet has been
shared with a non-human intelligence for
a large part of Humanity's existence and
I'm told that some of the best archives
and information historically on this is
stored in the Vatican the other word
that stuck out to me was the what the
Legacy program like though like there's
a single one this to me sounds like this
would be a multi-department and a
multi-program
program so why is there just one
I think it's a euphemism that's become
quite common inside the program as it's
called it's called the program that's
the euphemism that people have used to
it and uh I think those of us who are
passing comment on it have referred to
it often as the Legacy program because
essentially it's been a continuing
program that never stopped operating
throughout the Cold War
um and it continues to this day
one of the issues though and you quite
rightly make this point is that it's now
fragmented I think the the allegations
of my sources not just Mr grush are that
um
this program is now administered across
different private aerospace companies
um notably one of them of course is
Lockheed Martin
um I think those companies should be
asked directly whether they have had or
have possession of non-human technology
that at one stage was in the position of
the US government and uh are they going
to be obligating their um
uh requirements to respond under the new
legislation that's coming up before the
Congress
uh it's going to be very interesting to
see what they say because I think that
one of the one of the big issues here is
and I say this as somebody who's trained
in intellectual property law
they might rightly think it's their
property why the hell should they have
to account for this to the U.S
government if they've spent the money
and done the work in the last 60 70
years on trying to develop this
technology what business is it of the
U.S defense department or the US
government if they were properly vested
this material or if they recovered it
themselves
why should the US government have any
right over it I'm kind of on their side
on this you know frankly if Elon Musk
develops anti-gravity propulsion based
on a recovered piece of technology why
the hell should he have to account for
it to the U.S government or businesses
that are theirs if they've been so
incompetent is to hand over this
technology invested into private
Aerospace then I'm kind of on site I'm a
big fan of private Enterprise and
capitalism I think that the profit
motive drives some of the best
Innovations in technology
um if I was a private public here a
private Aerospace company that's
responsible to my shareholders I'd be
getting my lawyers briefed and ready for
a big fight with the Congress what
business is it of this I'm I'm kind of
with them in a way really uh you know
bottom line is if Lockheed Martin has a
flying saucer hidden in a Cupboard
somewhere and if they've spent billions
of dollars on trying to develop that
technology
why should they be putting up being
bullied by U.S Congress what business is
it of Congress if some president in the
past made the decision to divest the US
government of this technology or to take
it out of say the department of energy
50 60 years ago why were they completely
divest themselves the government
completely give this technology up and
not say hey Private Industry you have
great technology to investigate this
technology let's work together that's a
very good question Kurt I I one
explanation that I heard is that um
there was concerns that the department
of energy in particular was going to be
brought under the control of various
Regulatory Agencies notably the
government Accounting Office the GAO and
I'm told that at one stage the GAO was
asking some very shrewd questions about
monies and expenditure relating to the
program and a decision was made to
divest that technology from the doe into
private Enterprise
and unless proper contracts were drawn
up at the time that required that this
technology remained the property of the
US government
well frankly my friend if I was a clever
IP lawyer I would be saying stuff the US
government this is ours you know we're
one of the world's top aerospace
companies why should we have to hand
this over I'm kind of sympathetic with
them and I think if they came out
publicly and actually said that and said
yeah we've got this technology but it's
none of your Bloody Business piss off
leave us alone you know we're spending
the money
we've got the scientists we're spending
the dough if the US government was
stupid enough to go off and fight wars
in the Middle East in the last 10 15 20
years and not spend money on a Manhattan
style project to the back engineer alien
technology than it's their fault yeah I
mean I think we're actually a very
interesting point here where the
implications of
this
extraordinary legislation where clearly
what's going on behind the scenes here
is the Congress is pissed off it's upset
that it's asked it's demanded it's
already required under the ndaa laws
that people come forward with evidence
of uaps and they know it exists they
know that evidence is there that's
what's driving this legislation the
reason why Senator gillibrand is pushing
for aerospace companies or private
corporations to be forced to reveal
whether they've got objects of non-earth
origin or exotic UAP material is because
they've got witnesses who've already
told them about it and if I'm I don't
know let's just say Lockheed Martin and
they've got a flying saucer sitting in a
Cupboard somewhere they might think well
hell guys
that one there we recovered it ourselves
from Guatemala a few years ago why the
hell should we tell you about that it's
none of your business we're a private
company free enterprise is what a
Marriott made America great
Stick it and stick that in your pipe and
smoke it these loopholes characterize
the states and perhaps Canada maybe
Australia
is this something that's occurring
worldwide because I don't imagine that
these loopholes exist in Russia or in
China and I don't see why it wouldn't
leak and you did mention that some I
don't recall exactly what but some parts
of this have leaked but I don't know if
it's related to this anyway what do you
say to that let's deal with your country
I know for a fact that Canadian
scientists are actively involved in
working and collaborating with the
United States on retrieved non-human
technology there
let's just see if any of your media now
go out and ask questions about it
I don't think they will because they'll
be cowed they won't even go under
pressure one reasonable thing to do
would be to go to a press conference and
ask the Canadian defense minister with
the cameras rolling Minister what
inquiries have you done as a result of
the letter from Larry McGuire A Member
of Parliament who told you that he is
aware of a reverse engineering program
with which Canadian scientists have been
collaborating through your drdc for
decades with the US government
is she going to answer that question
she should
now let's deal with Australia I've
spoken to very senior people in my
government who've told me they know
nothing about any Australian involvement
in reverse engineering and I think
that's true I think that there have been
individual military personnel mainly
from our special forces who have
collaborated in retrievals I've spoken
to people who've alleged to me that
they've been involved in retrieval
operations
um I do believe that it's possible that
technology has been tested on Australian
territory or over our Sovereign Waters
without our knowledge
and I I'm investigating that at the
moment
let's deal with the UK I think the UK
knows a lot more than Canada or
Australia it's been a very active member
of the five eyes through the foreign
material program because there have been
retrievals in the United Kingdom and in
Europe I am told it is alleged to me I
don't know that for sure but the
allegation that has been put to me and
that includes British Special Forces
Personnel is that there have been active
operations crash retrievals even within
the last few years this has been an
ongoing issue
and people may say oh well how come
these things are crashing if these are
such advanced technology why are they
crashing so much often they're not
crashing they're just retrieved we don't
know the circumstances in which they
came to be where they are
but I'm told it has been alleged to me
that on occasion there have been fully
functioning Technologies recovered
with no visible damage to them
uh now
under the foreign materials program as
is detailed in the Larry McGuire letter
which is a secret five eyes agreement
for the recovery recovery
normally of foreign adversary technology
like Russia or China like the latest Meg
or the latest rocket system and things
like that it's happening a lot at the
moment inside Ukraine
um I'm told that through that FMP the
foreign materials program there have
also been very controversial and very
secret recoveries of what people believe
is non-human technology
but if you're a soldier a special forces
operative and you're cleared to be
involved in a retrieval operation like
that the level of knowledge that you
have is limited to your to your utility
you know it could very well be they've
just been standing there with a rifle
making sure nobody comes on scene while
scientists and officials move in and
remove whatever it is
so it may very well be they have no
direct knowledge themselves as to
exactly what it is and they're open to
the accusation that what they're talking
about might just be a Russian satellite
or a Chinese
drone or something like that
this is why this needs to be
investigated because
one of the things that I am aware of is
that there is an intelligence take there
is distribution of
five eyes intelligence now and it's
become much more routinized than it ever
used to be and within the last few years
there is now intelligence sharing on
uaps within the five eyes Alliance and
I've spoken to people in Australia
who've told me that they've seen some of
this take very senior people in our
intelligence community
and when I've said to them should we
discount this claim of
collaboration inside the five eyes on
alleged retrievals they've giggled and
said no I wouldn't I wouldn't put it
past the Americans at all and one of the
phenomena that's quite common here in
Australia one of the things that I've
reported on as a journalist reporting on
the intelligence community
has been it's been a long-standing
practice for Australia Canada and New
Zealand as kind of Junior partners of
the five eyes Alliance to do plausibly
deniable faders for their big brother
allies in the U.S and the UK and so
during the Cold War it's now public
information that Australians new
zealanders often collaborated with the
Brits or the Americans to bug or to tap
foreign embassies or foreign
adversary companies countries buildings
and we did plausibly deniable favors for
our friends
I'm told also that we've been involved
in retrievals of and quite rightly so
it's a good thing that we've been doing
this retrievals of Chinese and Russian
and North Korean technology you know
we're keeping tabs on our potential
enemies
but I'm also told because I've had chats
with people who've been involved in
these operations that there have been
retrievals where what's being retrieved
is obviously far more controversial
and I think the Brits know a lot more
about this because they've been more
actively involved and there is a high
level of collaboration between
um the UK and the and the us on this
issue but it's interesting because
um certainly the Parliamentary oversight
committees in the United Kingdom that
I've engaged with they're not aware of
this so again there's a there's an
accountability issue here if British
military or intelligence have been
involved I don't think their
parliamentary committees know about it
and frankly I think they should
I mean I'll give you an example I I did
a story in 1994. that's how old I am
um about how operatives of our
Australian secret intelligence service
are equivalent if you like of the CIA
assisted the British government in
bugging Kuwaiti government offices
after the first Gulf War
to procure a trade advantage to win
contracts against which Australia was
competing
and the operatives that were involved in
that operation told me how they were
paid cash by the Brits and told not to
tell their Australian Masters what
they'd been doing bugging Kuwaiti
government offices to help the British
win contracts against the Australians
and there was a royal Commission of
inquiry which essentially is a bit like
a grand jury investigation uh which
looked into this issue and the whole
issue of plausibly deniable favors by
our intelligence Community to assist uh
Big Brother allies the UK and the US was
brought to the fore
IGN
that I became aware of when I did the
story in 1994 was that when the Chinese
government was negotiating with the
British about the Handover of Hong Kong
back to China
um Australian government operatives were
involved at the behest of the British
sis in bugging Chinese government
offices in Hong Kong so that they could
negotiate a strategic advantage in the
negotiations with the Chinese
and imagine the consequences for
Australia if we'd been caught by the
Chinese and doing that kind of high
level spying I mean the blowback would
have been enormous and so I raised in my
story the issue of why we were doing
these plausibly deniable faders
this is the same thing that's been going
on with uaps because Larry McGuire in
his letter to the Canadian minister of
defense specifically raises how he's
concerned that upcoming public
announcements will be coordinated
between orcas which could damage
Canada's credibility with our allies
and orcas it's not a very well-known
agreement but it's the Australia UK U.S
agreement and what it is is essentially
a collaboration defense agreement which
is essentially targeting providing
Australia with nuclear submarine
technology it's bringing Australia into
the um into the nuclear world
controversially uh huge controversy in
Australia we're spending 400 billion
dollars on nuclear attack submarines
probably the Virginia class American
submarines in the next 20 to 30 years
not
I know
my prime minister in Australia and my
defense minister and the heads of our
intelligence services in government do
not know about the crash retrieval
program if it exists the Australian
crash retrieval or the no no no the U.S
Canadian crash retrieval collaboration
if I was Australia and I'm about to
spend nearly half a trillion dollars on
Weaponry which is supposedly the top of
the line Weaponry in the world I would
expect as a five eyes Ally partner to be
brought into the loop on the fact that
the U.S is potentially sitting on vastly
more Superior technology
I would expect that it would be a
legitimate question for my government to
be asking are we being sold a lemon
are we being sold technology that will
be superseded within five to ten years
if and when the American government
finally admits the truth of what this
alleged crash retrieval program involves
alleged technology that is capable of
extraordinary energy from the vacuum
extraordinary propulsion systems that
are capable of instantaneous velocity
the performance characteristics
manifested in the five observables
that's a technology I would want in
preference to a nuclear attack summary
and so this is why this is relevant to
agreements like the orcus agreement are
members of the five eyes Alliance who
have historically been treated as and
patronized as Junior partners are they
being locked out of information and
knowledge that ought properly to be
being shared with them to assist them in
making decisions about their future
National Security
that's why this now matters I'm not
trying to drive a wedge between the five
eyes Partners but I have had discussions
with people in my government in
Australia where I've said look I know
stuff that Canada is allegedly involved
in and you may not want to ask about it
but I think there is the beginning of a
realization now in my government in
Australia that they haven't been told
the whole story
um I suspect for example that there are
facilities in Australia that have been
used for experimentation with some of
this technology by the US government as
places like Groom Lake and um Area 51
became more and more scrutinized and hot
vast empty areas of Australia and our
ocean
uh beautiful places to practice
technology
and in my book in plain sight I start
the book by talking about an
extraordinary sighting multiple
corroborated where a gigantic black
triangular craft hovered silently over
two policemen and a civilian woman
and did performance parameters
performance characteristics far beyond
known human technology
and that's a technology that has been
seen by multiple witnesses that I've
since spoken to clearly something was
operating over North West Australia back
in the early 90s that has never been
properly explained and clearly the
Americans knew about it and tried to
shut people down from talking about it
and so it's funny and I I I I I I I
obviously get frustrated with um
stories like this one and our national
newspaper where the whole issue of um
alien conspiracies are mocked and you
know there really are references to
Little Green Men and that sort of
nonsense and it's this kind of
belittling ridicule that ignores the
fact that there is an abundance of
evidence no longer circumstantial
to suggest that there is something going
on the Pentagon has admitted the reality
of the phenomena it has admitted that
there is an anomalous phenomena possibly
intelligently controlled doing things
showing performance parameters that we
cannot explain
multiple hundreds thousands of witnesses
have seen objects doing things
that are apparently craft under
intelligent control showing performance
parameters that just cannot be explained
within known human technology
there is old intelligence Source by the
name of David grush who has come forward
and courageously spoken at for the first
time publicly saying that he is aware of
a crash retrieval program that has been
illegally kept secret from the American
public
um he's also alleged by the way bodies
and some journalists seem very shy about
even discussing that issue because
they're worried and confronted that
people may find it so ontologically
shocking that they don't want to talk
about it
this is real these allegations are being
made they should be being investigated
that's all David grush wants
about that triangle do you think that we
have the ability to operate forget about
reverse engineer I'll refer you to again
one of the episodes of need to know
www.needtoknow.today I
um I interviewed a former British
Special Forces soldier called John
Chapman he's a former British para very
highly trained British soldier
he was literally in combat in Ukraine in
the very early days of the battle around
Kiev in April last year he was with a
group of Navy SEALs Special Forces
soldiers from all over the world an
international Battalion that was
fighting behind Russian lines
and in the interview that he did with me
he and his colleagues described seeing
firstly three
strange lights appear in the sky in the
night sky
and then all of a sudden a triangular
craft winked into existence
and the way he's described it it
appeared to be operating as some kind of
surveillance and reconnaissance platform
it silently moved above the battlefield
literally as they're getting mortared
they're looking up and they're
describing it they're seeing it they're
absolutely categorical that they saw it
I've corroborated that this was seen
some kind of triangular surveillance
platform was being used on the
battlefield clearly monitoring Russian
positions in the very early days of the
Kiev offensive by the Russians
I don't know who that was
but something was taking an interest and
that platform that triangular object has
been seen by multiple Witnesses all
around the world
now I know people love to dismiss all
this as a wacky conspiracy theory and
they love to sort of push the idea that
this is just a conspiracy theory and
it's pushed by crazy people with Little
Green Men agendas
that's no longer the case that this is
uh being rationally suggested by sober
men and women at a very high level in
the American governments both in Canada
and the US I've had conversations with
people in your government
you know they privately admit to me that
they know something's going on but
they're frightened of asking you know
it's almost like oh well we kind of
assume it's in the National Goods so
we're not going to push any harder
but I think that's what the people
who've been hiding this all these years
have been playing on I think they have
periodically been people inside the US
government who have an oversight role
one of them is perhaps Admiral Tom
Wilson the Wilson document as we've
discussed previously occurred and I
remember I think and I think people have
stumbled across the issue from time to
time and I think they've bought the line
that this is a national security
imperative and that they shouldn't push
any harder
but I'm sorry it's clear to me now from
talking to the sources that I've spoken
to and this is clearly what the Congress
is finding out as well that they've been
illegalities if not criminal breaches of
the law one of the allegations that
David grush made to me in my interview
is that people have been murdered he
suspects to protect this Secret
now that is one hell of an allegation
and at some stage he's going to have to
put up the evidence to prove that
allegation
he's obviously spoken to people on the
inside in the program who've told him
this my understanding is that he has
testified about this in secret to the
Congress
my understanding is that he's also come
forward to the Inspector General at
intelligence and security about this
now what's interesting is is the
Congress going to do its job and ask the
questions that need to be asked to
investigate that is there the political
will at both Congressional and
senatorial level to actually push in a
public way for this to be made public
I'm not sure that it is
we live in such dangerous times you know
we've teetered in the last 24 48 Hours
on the edge of a horrible confrontation
in Russia that could have resulted in
Civil War in Russia either way even
though Putin's a thug it would have been
a very bad solution to have open Warfare
on Russian national territory
we're looking at the moment of at the
likelihood that there's going to be an
intervention if it can't be negotiated
to stop Iran from developing and you'd
be a weapon before the end of this year
I don't see how that can be avoided
military conflict will have to happen
unless a negotiated settlement can occur
there is no way Israel or the us are
going to allow any kind of nuclear bomb
to be developed by Iran
you've got the continuing nut job in
North Korea with his wacky ICBM uh
trials where he's trying to demonstrate
a capacity to launch icbms at the
continental United States
and then you've got China you've got the
ever-present risk of China and
you know I'm being told routinely by
officials in my government and in the
U.S government that it's only a matter
of time before we're at war with China
18 to 24 months is the time scale that
I'm being told
God forbid why in Hell's name do we
think that we can win a war with China I
do not know but in the context of all of
this do you think the Congress is going
to devote a lot of time and resources
and energy to pushing for a hugely
embarrassing expose to be revealed of
criminal corruption inside the military
and intelligence establishment
concealing an alleged crash retrieval
and reverse engineering program
involving retrieved non-human technology
for the last 80 years I don't think so
in other words as important as we find
it we're like this is the most important
subject the government's like you don't
know how close to Annihilation we are
from other sources it's not the most
yeah I mean I'm being I'm talking all
the time to people in
the US government who genuinely want
this issue out but in the scheme of
things
they're more focused quite legitimately
on making sure that Ukraine has enough
has artillery shells to be able to take
out the command structure of the Russian
government
I mean I I I don't think uaps are as big
a priority as they should be
and that's the tragedy because as David
grush admitted to me in his interview
actually I don't think a lot of this is
in the so far so far broadcast interview
but he's deeply skeptical about the
reasons why we went for war in Iraq you
know um and Afghanistan you know a lot
of good men and women have died they've
given their lives
uh for a conflict in the Middle East
that it was of dubious dubious
prominence you know why I mean what
benefit was derived from fighting that
war
imagine if the trillions of dollars that
were expended on the Middle Eastern
conflict had instead been expended on
a Manhattan style project where there
was collaborative science between men
and women in science from all over the
world to develop Energy Technologies and
propulsion systems that could
revolutionize human civilization
that's what people are talking about
now I don't know for sure that that
technology exists because I haven't seen
it but I have spoken to people who've
told me that it does exist I have spoken
to people who've urged me to push for
the public disclosure of the existence
of this technology and that's one of the
reasons why David Rush has come forward
he's the first of many
but those other Witnesses are watching
on and they're seeing how David grush
gets treated if he's treated badly if
he's treated if he's treated
perimeterally and dismissed then the
world doesn't deserve to know frankly
and I mean I appeal to your I mean one
of the things I love about your show
Curtis you get in a phenomenally
well-informed audience you have highly
intelligent people mainly from science
but also thought leaders who are
listening to your show and they
understand that you give people like me
the time to explain
and I I don't know if I can begin to
convey the depth of emotion and
frustration that good science oriented
people feel
that they can't talk publicly about what
they know that's being concealed right
there
maybe they're lying to me maybe the many
people that I've spoken to have all
contrived to lighterly maybe it's just a
massive disinformation program and maybe
the whole U.S Congress has been misled
to the extent that they now believe
credulously that there might be things
of non-earth origin held within private
Aerospace
respect there is
and imagine the consequences for the
world if that's true
imagine if for example
there is a technological Discovery to be
made that could make fossil fuels
redundant overnight
if that exists
and if these Technologies exist as they
appear to do
that this is that this is the
frightening thing about this is this
dissonance between what we know the fact
that this technology clearly exists even
sean Kirkpatrick the the head of Arrow
is begrudgingly admitting that these
metallic spheres are anomalous and that
he cannot explain them and there's no
explanation for how they're manipulating
themselves under their own control when
they've got no visible means of
propulsion
you've got that something is doing
things we cannot explain right and yet
there is this regulus
media acceptance
of a continuing disinformation program
that is run now for 60 to 70 years that
we should just accept the glib
assertions of the Pentagon that Arrow
has no credible evidence to support
evidence of ET
well for one Arrow wouldn't know because
it's not set up to do that job
it's not set up to proactively
investigate if you want to know this
story if you want to get to the truth
you have to do what Dave crushed is he
kicked doors in he knocked on doors he
Tracked Down people he did proactive
investigation that's why what he did is
different and that's why if we're
talking about intelligence sources that
are being given credibility by the
mainstream media don't give credibility
to the allegations of an anonymous
source like curveball who any reasonable
investigator back in 2003 could have
found was a put up by the Inc did they
find out who curveball was by the way
yeah they did yeah yeah yeah and this is
a story that really hasn't been told I
mean I'm fascinated by this story
because like a lot of Australian
journalists I was briefed by our
intelligence Community about how we
should accept the assurances of the
American government that this Source was
impeccable and that they were providing
red hot intelligence from right within
the WMT program within Saddam Hussein's
government military and it turned out it
was a lie it was a fabrication pushed by
Ahmed chalabi in the Iraqi National
Congress to push America to go to war in
Iraq and essentially what it did you
know who it benefited the Iranians and
that's why essentially Iraq is now a
proxy state of Iran
nobody's thought about this okay I don't
know much about the media and Ross you
were at least steeped in it so why isn't
it that when you get some report from
the government when you're telling it to
people to the public you don't say that
this is the case rather you say this
comes from the government by the way the
government has been truthful in the past
some not so truthful so take it with a
grain of salt
here's what they say
okay so when the government puts up a
press release as Susan Goff from the
Pentagon has said that Arrow has no
credible evidence of E.T or whatever it
is she said
why does the media not do the analysis
that I'm suggesting it should be doing
which is okay she spoke there for Arrow
but what about the Pentagon what about
the entire intelligence Community what
about Avril Haynes the Director of
National Intelligence Mystic Rush makes
the direct allegation in my interview
that he personally provided a copy of
his complaint to the dni to Avril Haynes
why has nobody gone to her and said ah
dni by the way there's a guy called Dave
grush he's made allegations to the
inspectors General and also to two of
the main oversight committees for the
intelligence community in Congress he's
alleging there are aliens there's a
non-human intelligence he's alleging
you've recovered non-human technology
and bodies he's alleging that people
have been murdered to cover up this
Secret
now
okay it's a big ontological shock to ask
that question and if you're a journalist
and you've got the dni Avril Haynes in
front of you you take a Big Gulp before
you ask but by golly you should be
asking the question and when Kareem
Jean-Pierre the White House Press
Secretary was asked the same question
the other day and she duck passed and
said you'll have to ask the Pentagon
about that why did the Press Gallery the
White House Press Corps just let her get
away with that why did not one
journalist in the room not stand up and
say no excuse me
we need to know where the White House
Press Corps our job is to find out and
report on what the president knows has
the president sought a briefing on Mr
grush's allegations what is the
president's response to Mr grush's
allegations was Jake Sullivan at a
secret meeting in the Congress where
some of these issues regarding crash
retrievals were discussed why does you
know has the National Security advisor
provided a report to the president on
this issue
that's the sort of investigative
journalism that needs to be happening
here and I think what the American
public what the world needs to be asking
is why those questions aren't being
asked this isn't some wacky conspiracy
theory we're way beyond that now as I
said at the beginning of this
conversation two hours ago we're now
over three weeks into David crush's
allegations and the Pentagon the
intelligence Community nobody has laid a
glove on his credibility
everybody
Colonel Carnell uh Jonathan gray the guy
who uses the pseudonym from nasic and
Christopher melon three independent
Witnesses have verified to his
credibility on the issue of Crash
retrievals and reverse engineering
why in the face of that multiple
corroboration has no one in the U.S
national media Then followed it up and
gone you know what
that is a good question
why can't the president be asked this
why can't the Director of National
Intelligence be asked these questions
since when did the U.S national media
especially in light of the fact that
they were lied to and deceived at the
time of the last Gulf War with false
Source intelligence why can't they now
go back and ask the White House the
truth of these claims
that's the only way that this will ever
change when the mainstream media picks
up the ball and runs with it and and
frankly I'm not confident they will I've
called The New York Times and the what
Washington Post gutless cowards for for
not running with this and they are they
are gutless cowards and it's because
frankly they don't want to offend their
sources because in defense intelligence
that's not because they think that the
public is going to say hey I can't
believe you're taking this seriously and
then they'll feel like they'll get
ridiculed but but is that is that really
the responsibility of the media should
the media really be looking at whether
or not the Public's going to believe
them or not it's not the media's role
the media's role is without fear or
favor to investigate allegations to test
the evidence and to put the claims to
the people in authority and even now
we're getting on towards a month since
David grush made his allegations and
went public there has been no attempt by
The Washington Post the New York Times
the LA Times the Chicago Sun Times the
Boston Globe none of those great
newspapers of the United States have
sought to put these allegations to the
people in power
and I just think the world needs to ask
why
what's going on behind the scenes why
are they so frightened of asking the
question why is it that when the issue
was raised in the White House Press Room
and the White House Press Secretary was
asked you know what's the story about
these claims about aliens
um why is it that the White House Press
Secretary was allowed to get away with
just duck passing the issue and flicking
it across to the Pentagon
why is that satisfactory I don't
understand and the media that I've grown
up with the the kind of the it could
also just be that they're not as
informed as you to know hey Arrow isn't
supposed to be the place that has the
knowledge of this
no the no the the problem is that much
of the mainstream media is working
towards an operant Prejudice they're not
operating it objectively and it's sad
they're operating according to the
prejudices that are catered to them by
the sources they speak to
and you know I've sat around the lunch
tables and the the quiet little chat
server a glass of wine with intelligence
officials I know how it works they
delicately put down poison for
propositions and it's made very clear
that if you're going in that direction
you're going the wrong way can you give
me an example
oh well you know um at the time of the
last Gulf War if people had actually
investigated whether or not there was
any truth to the allegations that Iraq
was um uh involved in um making weapons
of mass destruction I mean there was
evidence for example that one of the
things that was relied upon was claims
that an Australian company was involved
unknowingly in the production of
um aluminum tubing that it was suspected
was being made to such a high level that
it was capable of being used in a
centrifuge process to process uranium
and it turned out there were real dats
about that evidence and the people who
were in the company involved were
genuinely shocked that this allegation
was being made and I was one of the
journals that was basically being
approached and asked to investigate that
issue but essentially the ability for us
to investigate that was drowned out by
the assertion from the U.S intelligence
community that they had rock-solid
intelligence from largely this witness
curveball that we were um very sure that
there were weapons of mass destruction
and they would be found as soon as we
got into Iraq and the reality is as was
born out by the subsequent
investigations there was no truth to the
allegation at all
I mean an example of the poison over
wine
oh I mean I mean that's what I'm saying
is that if if journalists had gone and
investigated the aluminum tubes
allegation as they sought to do they
would not get invited to the next press
briefing for the defense department you
know you'd get cut off the drip and one
of the worst things that can happen for
a newspaper that's competing with
stories with other newspapers or a TV
station for that matter is you don't get
invited to be say the embedded
correspondent with I don't know General
Schwarzkopf or whoever the Commanding
General is you don't get invited inside
the tent and so one of the issues for
media organizations is access you only
get these stories if you have access and
unfortunately
um I think especially in the last
20 or so years since 9 11. you know one
of the other stories for example that I
find fascinating because I've done a lot
of Stories on privacy and surveillance
is the revelation of illegal wiretapping
by the National Security Agency and that
was a story that a lot of us knew about
um that was widely circulating and the
media were terrified of touching it and
um you know there were attempts to shut
the media down through uh the fisa uh
legislation you know there was an
attempt to meddle with the editorial
direction of news departments there were
really strong Heavies put on the media
in the U.S to not report that story it's
been well told I mean I I can't name off
the top of my head The Correspondents
who were responsible for eventually
breaking the story but one of the major
newspapers eventually courageously
revealed the story and indeed went on to
win the Pulitzer but the uh the simple
fact is that there was a real pushback
that you know you can't report this
because to do this would be to
compromise National Security you know to
reveal extensive allele illegal
wiretapping as to compromise National
Security and it was rubbish essentially
what had happened because there was an
over misinterpretation of the
intelligence laws that um wrongly in the
opinion of the intelligence bosses gave
them the power to do the warrantless
tapping that they were doing
and the only reason that that was
stopped and brought under proper
regulation was because there was media
expose of it happening and sadly I think
that's what's going to have to happen
here there's going to have to be media
expose eventually of I suspect a leak
from Congress I think that's what will
probably happen at some stage somebody
from the gang of eight or somebody from
one of the congressional committees will
eventually not be able to control
themselves and reveal yeah actually you
know what grush told the truth
but until then I think the media is
going to be a willing Lick spittle in
continuing the cover-up
I think it's convinced itself that it's
all and they've never devoted
the resources to properly investigate it
and that's the tragedy the the tragedy
is that there is a default ridicule and
taboo that is attached to the subject of
uaps you know if you even mention to an
editor that you want to do a UFO story
this is kind of ironic grin that comes
across their face and it's a default
stigma and frankly in the face of the
enormous amount of evidence most notably
the Senate intelligence bill that refers
to objects of non-earth origin or exotic
UAP material surely to God it's now time
to get beyond the ridicule and the
contempt to Traverse the taboo and start
asking the hard questions
earlier I asked about if the Americans
or anyone has the ability to control the
craft forget about reverse engineering I
didn't hear an answer
oh well that's speculation I don't know
for sure I mean on one analysis it's
claimed that the US has not been able to
reverse engineer much at all
successfully and that's the line that I
think um on his own admission Dr Eric
Davis who's investigated the crash
retrieval program passed on to Alejandro
Rojas in interviews he did about four or
five years ago
um I think he claimed for example that
it had been so unsuccessful that back in
1989 the program was actually shut down
for a while or put on hold
other people tell me that there's been
quite notable successes and I think the
reason for the dissonance the reason for
the disagreement about what has actually
happened is that we may in fact be
talking about like we use the term the
Legacy program
but I think part of the problem is
in my line of work we have a saying
always assume a screw-up before a
conspiracy and I'm inclined to believe
there's been a screw-up here
I suspect I don't know for sure I
suspect that from the early 50s onwards
the decision was made that the analysis
of these objects these craft was best
done by private Enterprise oriented
companies big aerospace companies that
had the resources and the technical
know-har to do the work so that
divesting that you're referring to
earlier they divested these objects
these craft into their control
and I suspect there's been a screw-up I
suspect the US government didn't write
contracts they didn't want to put
anything in writing I don't I don't
think they gave themselves any IP any
intellectual property control over that
material
and I think this is part of the problem
this is why this legislation is now
necessary because the Congress has
revealed from witnesses that it's quite
likely that the military has no idea
what has been done or achieved inside
private Aerospace
I've had allegations that I have not
been able to confirm put to me that
certain companies notably British
Aerospace have actually made notable
achievements in developing this
technology
but I haven't been able to verify that
because of course the private aerospace
companies they have a formidable ability
to use private military and intelligence
contractors to cover their Trail they're
not accountable to government or
government agencies there's no ability
to scrutinize them unless you have
people on the inside speaking out which
I have but I'm unfortunately not able to
talk about them in much detail because
they're too terrified
but the simple fact is I think it's
possible that there are
programs ongoing in private Aerospace
that are actually not within the
knowledge of many of the people in the
military intelligence Community who
supposedly have Carriage of this and I
suspect it's a screw-up I suspect that
what happened was over the years it
became formalized that we would entrust
these private aerospace companies to do
the work and nobody ever thought gee who
owns this technology
gee shouldn't we be monitoring them and
and letting Congress know so that we can
report to Congress the success of any
efforts to develop this technology
I don't think that happened and that's
why
always assume a screw-up before a
conspiracy that's my Mantra and I think
if you assume us grew up before a
conspiracy that's what's happened here I
don't think these private aerospace
companies think they've done anything
wrong yeah sure I suspect people
probably have been killed and hurt and
intimidated and threatened along the way
to cover this up
private Enterprise is capable of doing
terrible things so is government
but
I don't know that government necessarily
knows about this and this is why
Congress is now trying to get to the
truth
and so to those in the mainstream media
who have parentally dismissed this all
these years and gone ah there's nothing
in this my sources and intelligence are
telling me there's nothing in this just
laugh about it just ignore it when it
comes up in press conferences titter
slightly and and you know follow along
with everyone else and just laugh about
it
some of these journals just need to grow
a spine and start asking hard questions
and I think sooner or later the um
what's it called the truth embargo will
break uh it's a great term I like it
it's a good name the truth embargo I
think there really is I think there's a
knowing reluctance to ask the question
and I think the reason why is because at
the bottom of it it's a stuffer up more
often than not it's not a bunch of
Gatekeepers actively with full knowledge
of the cover-up trying to cover it up
more often than not it's a bunch of
two-bit generals and flunky intelligence
officials who frankly realize belatedly
that they've presided over a very
shambolic assigning of Technology into
private Aerospace
and they're terrified about the
consequences for the us if it comes out
that the US actually doesn't own this
technology
you know we've probably devoted
scientists and material resources to
help investigate it for years but
there's never been a lawyer who's
actually sat down and gone
so guys who actually owns this stuff
and that's where we're at now that's the
unloading of the crafts of the tech but
what about the bodies did they also
unload that and then who would they give
that to good question
don't you think Congress should be
asking that question and don't you think
if somebody of the reputation and
caliber an undoubted reputation of David
grush comes forward and makes an
allegation like that
why is it legitimate for
even journalists investigating this
story to not even mention the bodies
you know some of my colleagues have said
that we shouldn't talk about bodies why
I mean if these things were piloted that
means somebody was piloting them what
happened to those entities to those
beings if they exist it could be
autopilot though it could be
but Mr grush is alleging that there have
been bodies recovered now he said that
under oath
so
has he lied to the inspectors General
has he lied to the Congress
the consequences for him are enormous if
he's lied
why would he lie like that
think about it I mean seriously you've
got a very courageous I happen to think
David grush is one of the most
courageous whistleblowers to come
forward in recent American history
it's like it's as if deep throat had
gone public
you know at the time he we now know he
was the he was the deputy director of
the FBI
but it's as if deep throat had gone
public and said I'm alleging that the
president has been involved in a
criminal conspiracy
and now you've got the situation where
are we to assume that the Washington
Post and the New York Times journalists
award would have gone let's just ignore
him he's he's only the deputy director
of the FBI you know deep throats it's my
understanding about grush and the alien
bodies that he never saw them he's
saying that I was told about them or
that I saw a picture of him so yeah he
could say under oath that I believe it
to be the case that there's alien he has
he has said what he has said what he has
said to me is I have a strong suspicion
that people have been hurt or murdered
well that's the answer that he gave in
in implicit acknowledgment of the
question that I put to him and I think
that should be investigated don't you
what are we frightened of if it's not
true it's not true and sent Dave grush
to jail for the next 20 years for lying
under oath
but but why
don't you see could the the dissonance
between what he's saying publicly and
exposing the risk to himself
and and people in mainstream media who
call themselves journalists and more
importantly the policy leaders in
Congress the the politicians they've all
run like little chickens from these
allegations nobody very rarely has
anybody spoken at very few congressmen
or women or or um Senators have actually
spoken out publicly on this issue Larry
McGuire so that's Canadian is an Empire
Maguire Larry McGuire hasn't spoken
Beyond much but what he said in his
letter
why has nobody put him up on national TV
and said Mr McGuire let's be clear is
what you are saying based on stuff
you've got from reading a book
or have you got more solid evidence that
you've acquired because of your own
investigations and I suspect it's the
latter I'm told it's the latter
why are nobody asking those questions
don't you see I mean this is this is the
fundamental problem is there is a
willful
failure by media
investigative researchers
politicians to ask the question
why
why is there that willful failure so
Ross about the leaked that you said that
there are some leaked videos or leaked
evidence or I'm so sorry could I'm not
sure what you're referring to there can
you be more specific yeah yeah sure sure
in the beginning when we were talking
about a complaint is like not that many
people from the government come out and
there's not that much evidence that's
leaked from the government from
something that's as large as this oh
okay okay I mean historically
during the
course of what Mr grush alleges has been
a continuing disinformation operation on
uaps there are people who have come
forward and I I note interestingly
enough Stephen Greer did his disclosure
project thing the other day at the
national Press Club how do you feel
about that well it's interesting I I was
inclined because I'm I don't have a very
high opinion of
um Mr Greer to be honest I think on
occasion he has misrepresented his
Communications with government officials
and made them sound like briefings for
example he's claimed to have briefed a
former CIA director and I've engaged
with people who've told me the full
story and I don't believe he did a
briefing of a CIA director at all
um I don't know why he does this because
there are people in the Congress who've
told me that some of the witnesses that
Stephen Greer has provided to the
Congress in secret who've come forward
with evidence about the program have
indeed been highly credible Witnesses
and they they've been taken very very
seriously indeed
um the the I mean I just wish
um there was more
quality control with what Mr Grier says
as he comes through with his claims I
don't want to buy a fight with Stephen
Greer but I think on occasion he has
either inadvertently or otherwise
misrepresented the way in which he's
engaged with government
but I I do think that separately from Mr
Greer
um they have periodically publicly and
I'm not going to list them all here
because then people will realize who I'm
talking about but there have people
periodically bobbed up who have given
evidence of their their involvement in
alleged crash retrieval operations for
example and there's never really been if
you look at those cases a satisfactory
resolution of whether they're telling
the truth or not because they're clearly
people with security clearances they've
clearly worked in the military units
that they say they've worked in
and there's never a resolution of
whether or not they're telling the truth
or not because of course the only
Arbiter that can actually adjudicate
whether they're telling the truth or not
is the defense department which if what
Mr grush is alleging is true there are
individuals within the defense
department who have no interest at all
in letting this public information out
uh you know there's no interest at all
in publicizing this information
so that's my problem is that yes
periodically through history
I mean if you go right back to the days
of
the first director of the CIA Roscoe
hillenkotter
Roscoe hillencotta came out publicly and
set up at his own UFO investigation
organization because he was convinced
there was a cover-up
the head of the CIA
you know people have forgotten their
history in America
um
they've been um uh there's a lovely guy
on Twitter Richard gildrick and he's
been doing uh trawling of old media
reports and um
going right back to the 40s and the 50s
there were frequent allegations of
recovered flying sources that featured
in the media with first-person Witnesses
um
very little active work was done to
investigate those because of course by
that stage the taboo had been introduced
media were being taught to ridicule it
and the public was being taught that you
know if there was anything real there it
was National Security and not to be
talked about and people were shut down I
think the evidence is overwhelming that
Witnesses have been intimidated that
they've been threatened
um and indeed as Mr grush is telling the
truth that Witnesses have been killed I
mean it's a horrendous allegation again
why shouldn't that be being properly
investigated he's called their Bluff I
mean think about it as a journalist what
do you do when the government's like I
can't tell you it's for reasons of
National Security like what do you do
what do you say to that well privately I
say well why I mean seriously what why
would the fact that somebody's allegedly
been murdered to protect a secret be a
national security secret can they not
just say the reasons for that are also
Secrets I don't know how it works well I
mean do we glibly accept that I'm I mean
I guess I'd be asking and I have done on
occasion you know I've I've asked for
the reasons why something is classified
and often I've accepted the reasons why
it's classified
um
uh it's a it's a matter of negotiation
and Trust often but but this is the
problem is that
um a lot of media glibly accept what's
told to them by a security official oh
look you know this is classified can I
talk about it can't talk about it but
you know if this is a government program
and if it is a high National Security
program there is a possibility that
murdering people may be legal under the
intelligence laws of the day
I mean spies are allowed to kill you
know in the public interest we've killed
people through our intelligence services
to protect National Security interests
have people being killed was it legal
don't know but it should be investigated
people don't understand that you know if
if there is indeed this incredible
awesome technology that is being
secreted by the US government if that's
true
I'm not justifying this but I would
certainly as a security official be
trying to protect that secret to stop
the Russians and the Chinese from
getting access to it are you afraid for
your life no no not all I mean I accept
that I'm probably under surveillance
um I know that I am at times uh but
um you haven't been told hey stop
talking about it or some men in black or
some other no no no and I I think they
know I would go public if they did
I mean I I at the moment any threat like
that emerged I'd make my damndest to
make sure the world knew about it so no
intimidation no harassment no but the
witnesses that I'm talking to have been
intimidated they have been harassed and
they've been told on some occasions that
they would be murdered if they spoke out
about it I imagine Russia's afraid
probably he feels good that he feels
like he's doing the right thing I don't
know I don't know how that works neither
do I
neither do I my friend yeah okay to wrap
up you've been with us for quite some
time there's been talk from Leslie Kane
and John Ramirez that something's
occurring at the late 2020s 2027 2029 I
don't know I just know that these years
have been set out like some significant
event is gonna
happen what do you know about that
um uh look there are people who have
suggested to me that that there are
um apocalyptic events like catastrophic
um I were one of the ones I heard at one
stage was the reversal of the polls and
I don't know why that would cause any
calamitous geological changes but it was
suggested to me that there might be a
you know a calamitous movement of the
Earth's crust I was referred to the
so-called Adam and Eve story that's uh
apparently in part uh in a redacted form
in the CIA library but
um 2027 was mentioned at one time I've
heard other dates in the 30s uh I don't
know I've got no idea I have no leads
that make me feel strongly that this is
true I think it's speculative
um uh I just don't know you'd have to
ask Leslie or um
or John Ramirez and on John look to be
honest whilst I've spoken to John
um it's never entirely clear to me how
much of what John is talking about is
sourced to his past role as a
gs14 or gs15 in the CIA I.E a senior
public official
um
uh and how much of what he's doing is
speculating it almost like a hobby post
job I mean I I think I I'd like to see
John pin down more I've actually asked
him for an interview and he declined and
um said that he was um going back into
uh working in the top secret role
somewhere else and
um I've been amused to see that he's
subsequently gone on and spoken to other
people and the office still there for
John to speak to me because John if
you're watching go on need to know I
would I would like to talk to him I need
to know because I I'd like to clarify
with him whether what he's talking about
is derived from his CIA experience or
whether it's derived from I don't know
books that he's read or people that he's
spoken to post employment
for your news Nation story with David
grush how do you feel it went and what
would you do differently
um I
I'm happy we got the story out there and
I admire and respect news Nation for
Having the courage and the decisiveness
to actually run the story because
it was lion ball frankly for any U.S TV
network to make the decision to run the
story and they're not a top string TV
network they're a new aspiring News
Network
um and I think it's done them no end of
good they've had a massive increase in
their ratings as a result of the story
oh yes oh okay I thought you're saying
it's done them no good okay no no no
it's done them a world of good great
they're really happy that they've done
the story and they're now aware that
uaps are a story that people are
interested in
and this is the thing that I find
fascinating is that there's a wisdom of
the crowd here that the media Executives
in mainstream media they pompously
dictate what you and I get to read and
they assigned the op-ed writers to write
the nonsense ridiculing articles that
belittle the subject of uaps there's
that Mantra that um
rope that runs through how mainstream
media organizations traditionally deal
with the subject of uaps
but what I'm fascinated by as a journal
that's worked in that area is how
social media programs like yours are
superseding the role that used to be
played by mainstream media I mean you've
given me here over two and a half hours
to talk expansively
sure but I'm grateful for it because I
think the public need and want
long-form analysis of the UAP issue and
news Nation did that they created an
hour of prime time TV
um they've got the full interview with
Dave grush which I think runs about
three and a half hours I'd probably edit
it down to a tighter two hours I'd like
to run the the Fuller interview so that
people can see the full extensive
questions and answers that I put to Dave
and it would be my hope that in some
format we can run that at some stage
yeah what holds that back
uh good question you'd have to ask news
Nation
um I I'm hoping to be able to run it or
a version of a Dave grush interview on
need to know dot today at some stage
um if they're not going to uh because I
do think the small material that
properly to be poured into the public
domain and I I think also people want to
see grush being pressed in the way that
I did press him in the interview I think
in the news Nation story
um they did a fantastic job really
professional job really proud to have
been working with them and I hope I can
continue to work with them in the future
but
um the one thing I would have loved to
have seen more of is the competitive
interviewing and pressing of Mr grush
that we showed and the way that we
challenged him during the interview I
think people would understand more about
why I find Mr grush a highly credible
witness if they could see the question
and answer and Analysis that we do in
the course of the interview
and that's always a frustration with TV
because Network TV always wants to put
things into bite-sized chunks that fit
around the advertisements because
ultimately all news is is the stuff you
wrap around advertisements it's all
about selling selling Corn Flakes but
the um the the simple factors I think
the audience wants more and uh I'm
aspiring and hoping to be able to
provide them in some format with more
what a lot of people don't realize Kurt
is
um uh I laughed just recently because
somebody with Malayan intent created a
Wikipedia entry for me where they said
that cool tart
um is making the claims that he's making
in order to join the quote lucrative UAP
lecture circuit with Leslie Kane and
Ralph Blumenthal
and it's hilarious because I have never
earned a cent from any UAP lecture and I
really as you know I'm not being paid
for this interview with you where I've
given you nearly three hours of my time
and um frankly I I don't expect to be
and um or the work that I do is largely
unpaid and I do this work in conjunction
with an occasional day job that I do as
an investigative reporter for Australian
network television
and it's a hard gig they don't care that
you've had some Choice words about the
mainstream media
I think they share my view I mean I to
be honest with you I think most people
in mainstream media are depressed about
the way mainstream media is going it's
failing its audiences okay dumbing down
it's frightened of long-form analysis
and the irony is as the Dave Crush
interview showed when you give people
long-form analysis they love it they've
responded to it I mean news Nations
ratings were up multiple hundreds of
percent they're delighted with the
response that they had and I think
they've realized that this is a story
that should be being chased and more
importantly people have come out of the
woodwork and spoken to news Nations
supporting Dave crush's allegations in a
way that they didn't expect I think
they've been very pleasantly surprised
and I'm looking forward to making more
stories with them in the future I will
give you some questions to ask them
about some of the physics claims he had
sure
happy to do so he said something that
was interesting I can tell you right now
in a minute and a half do you want to
spend 90 seconds on this yeah sure it is
a well established uh fact at least
mathematically and based on empirical
observation and Analysis that there most
likely are physical additional spatial
dimensions and you can imagine
um four and five d space where what we
experience is linear time ends up being
a physical dimension for in higher
dimensional space where if you were
living there you could translate across
what we perceive as a linear flow so
there is a uh possibility that and this
is a theory here I'm not saying this is
100 the case but I don't mean to pick a
part it just stands out so he said I
don't quoting it's a well-established at
least mathematically and based on
empirical observation and Analysis that
there are likely physical additional
spatial dimensions and you can imagine
on four or five D's space where what we
experience is linear time ends up being
a physical dimension for higher
dimensional space if we living there you
could translate across what we perceive
as a linear flow and this is a theory
here I'm not saying this is 100 the case
okay so what's interesting firstly it
goes from this is a well-established to
then this is most likely to then this is
a possibility and then this is a theory
to then I'm not saying this is the case
and then secondly he then says it's well
established mathematically I don't think
it's established mathematically or
empirically that there are other
physical dimensions
it doesn't have anything to do with
quantum mechanics it's also false to say
that it's from a different dimension
because we're a part of the same
Dimension it's just a different value
within that same Dimension that linear
time isn't a term used in physics unless
dealing with computational complexity
like calculating
that's that's why you should see the
interview because
um I was I was pushing him at that point
I was basically saying well what are you
talking about where are these aliens
from and he goes they're not aliens
they're a non-human intelligence and and
one of the things we talk about is we go
into whether they've lived here on this
planet all these years and we get into
the issue whether they're um
uh whether they're um
uh actually on earth-based intelligence
so they're not extraterrestrial at all
they're intra-terrestrial
and uh and then
um we floated the idea that it might be
interdimensional and that's when he's
based in that area I see it and I'm not
trying to infer anything about no no no
he's not just he's not motivated he's
not weddings he's not wetting himself to
a theory of inter-dimensionality
um okay but basically he was offering
speculation uh because he's as
interested in it as you and I are uh
that you know one possible explanation
is this explanation okay now thank you
so much my only question is like I know
that you've spent so long with me and I
think this is the first podcast that
you've done since that story well it's a
thank you and why like what do I do to
deserve this it's an honor for me
um
I look I'm I'm not pissing in your
pocket here Kurt when I say that I love
your show because you let people talk
and you have a an understanding of
science because of your training and
physics
and you ask good questions you know
you've put me on the spot at times where
you've asked me to justify what I've
said I like being put on the spot
um it's fun it's what journalists should
do and the irony is it's a show like
yours that's doing the job that major
newspapers and television in mainstream
should be doing and so what's happening
at the moment is we're seeing a shift
my daughters God bless them they don't
watch TV news my wife and I watched the
six o'clock news every night and the TV
news and we like to see the network news
you know and we know the news anchor and
we read the newspaper and we're
religious about following the news every
day but I think we're the last
generation that are going to do that
one of my daughters told me she gets
most of her news from Tick Tock
um okay uh Instagram I mean I've had to
learn Robbie Williams of all people
followed me on um Instagram the other
day and recommended me to his audience
and my daughter who's a social media
marketer basically came to me and said
Dad
Robbie Williams followed you and I went
what does that mean sorry and she went
huge you know you should use Instagram
more and I win what's Instagram you know
I'm honestly truly I created an
Instagram account years ago to basically
monitor
um pictures of dogs that my wife sends
me but um I have to admit I've never
really used it for use dissemination and
what fascinates me is that there's a
younger generation that is impatient
with mainstream media they don't care
about it anymore they don't watch the
news they don't listen to Network
television or radio and those news
organizations are losing their audience
like when I first started in network
television I mean Australia is only a
country of um 27 million people but one
of the biggest stories I ever did was a
corruption exposure and I think we got
nearly 3 million
views which was just a massive huge
chunk of the national audience
and these days
a really good rating is 500 000 views in
network television
and the reason why I think is because
they're not doing the sort of stories
that you and I are interested in the
kind of long-form discursive analysis
that you do it's not for any coincidence
that shows like yours are doing really
well and drawing millions of views it's
because people are impatient with old
style Legacy Media all right Ross get
some coffee
you go and have a good night's sleep
Kurt I've kept you up way past your
bedtime mate yeah man I never do a
podcast this label for you
I'll wake up at 1am take care man
after this podcast over text I asked
Ross about the Indian situation with
regard to uaps as this whole topic seems
to be us focused here's what Ross said
and I won't even attempt to do his
accent hi Kurt I've spoken to Indian and
Pakistani officials and scientists but
they've confined what they've told me to
admissions that they have witnessed
Kraft and anomalous objects operating
quote unquote intelligently over no
nuclear facilities mainly weapons
repositories no one has indicated any
willingness or government intention for
disclosure quote unquote per se but
they're very open and willing to share I
think India is a verdant Pastor for
investigation no one's funding such
research that's the simple issue okay
thank you for watching this two maybe
even three hour podcast with Ross
coldheart the time just flies by
especially with Ross and hopefully you
enjoyed it I think you must have given
that you've watched all the way till
this point or perhaps you just skipped
through because you love to see my face
and who could blame you there are just
about seven quick announcements number
one you should know about the previous
conversation with Ross on this channel
the link is in the description like I
said before in the intro it's our most
viewed podcast in fact it has almost 2
million hits number two you should know
about the UFO playlist so we've spoken
to Les Stroud Avi Loeb Kevin knuth
Salvatore Pious jock Valley Jeremy
Corbell Lou Elizondo three times Jeremy
Corbell twice Richard Dolan twice
actually with the tonanza which is an
eight hour special Travis Walton Tom
Delong Linda Moulton Howe George Knapp
Gary Nolan Eric Weinstein had a Theo
locution with Mick West Stephen Greer
Leslie Kane and recently John Greenwald
thirdly you should know that there's a
video on the controversial history of
quantum gravity most people don't know
but quantum gravity owes its development
while general relativity the Renaissance
of it owes its development to
anti-gravity and interest in
anti-gravity with UFOs as well by two
private investors Agnew banson and Roger
absent it's a dark secret that most
people don't know about including many
in the physics community and so there's
this 30 minute documentary on that
subject fourthly there's a moderately
disputatious conversation with Neil
deGrasse Tyson it's either out now or
it's about to be out in a couple of days
with Neil and myself check it out it's
in the description we talk about UFOs AI
as well as the limitations of science or
Neil's eyes the unlimitations of science
fifthly there's an iTunes version of
this podcast a Spotify version basically
any audio platform that you listen to
podcasts from there's going to be
theories of everything you just search
it in case you want to re-listen many
people including myself I learned the
most when I re-watch or re-listen and if
you want to then please re-listen on
those places sixthly there's now toe
merch theories of everything merch
there's only three weeks left as of this
date the end of June right now 2023 this
will end in the middle of July we're
closing it down some of the references
you can get to it by going to tinyur
l.com tow merch and some of the
references you have to be a hardcore
told listener to understand like
distosher I agree with how you're
agreeing with me that one comes from
John verakee don't thrust your toe trust
your toe getting wet with Kurt don't
talk to me or I'll bring up Hegel true
nobility is being coordinate free that
one comes from the crash course on
physics that I had it's a two-hour crash
course on all of theoretical physics
like as best as I could compress it then
there's a toe hat there's I say face
base inorganically in everyday
conversation that one is something that
I noticed plenty of people do it's
babbling all the way down I have a toe
fetish okay I'm just a gym rat for toes
yeah that's something that I say because
that's all I do is study for toes I'm
just a gym rat for toes got Abby genasis
the voices are back excellent that one
comes from Gary Nolan himself so visit
tinyurl.com toe merch and pick up your
tone merch any of the merch that you
want you also twinly support the podcast
browse it see if there's something that
interests you seventhly and lastly
there's the black
toevault.com
theblattovault.com which is an AI tool
technically it's an llm which was
developed with the help of Dan VanZant
Daniel Van Zant and John Greenwald to
query John's foyer request database you
can visit
theblacktovault.com but what I recommend
you do instead is visit the link in the
description which is a few minutes long
clip about the behind the scenes of the
development of this tool this will help
you understand what it is and where it's
going what features will be added as
this is just a first step all right that
gets all of the announcements out of the
way thank you so much the podcast is now
concluded thank you for watching if you
haven't subscribed or clicked on that
like button now would be a great time to
do so as each subscribe and like helps
YouTube push this content to more people
you should also know that there's a
remarkably active Discord and subreddit
for theories of everything where people
explicate tolls disagree respectfully
about theories and build as a community
our own toes links to both are in the
description also I recently found out
that external links count plenty to war
toward the algorithm which means that
when you share on Twitter on Facebook on
Reddit Etc it shows YouTube that people
are talking about this outside of
YouTube which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well last but
not least you should know that this
podcast is on iTunes it's on Spotify
it's on every one of the audio platforms
just type in theories of everything and
you'll find it often I gain from
re-watching lectures and podcasts and I
read in the comments that hey toe
listeners also gained from replaying so
how about instead re-listening on those
platforms iTunes Spotify Google podcast
whichever podcast catcher you use if
you'd like to support more conversations
like this then do consider visiting
patreon.com
and donate whatever you like again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on toe full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you